e já está valendo então tá conversando
agora mais um pode que se chama mais um
pode porque é só mais um podcast né
Realmente a gente pega as coisas sejam
especiais e sejam diferente nosso meu
tem um diferencial não tem o meu é mesmo
alumínio luminárias mando fazer até no
mesmo lugar eu acho que todos os outros
e aí a gente vai proporcionar conteúdo
diferente aqui com as nossas convidadas
vamos fazer de conta que você não sabe
quem é porque você não viu na também nem
ler o título sabe quem está aqui com a
gente hoje ela mesmo bagunçando a
divisão esparramando lá gente
E aí
Oi tudo bom Carol tudo bem agora tá tudo
melhor agora mais calmo outro quantos
dias foi assim quando você saiu quantos
dias foi tipo para dizer assim ah não
agora eu tô respirando né nem tô
pensando nisso 24 horas por dia acho que
ainda tô num processo de ainda tá ainda
não tentando relaxar com tudo eu não sei
se você pode falar se não puder Retiro
depois nós tipo quando a gente tava
tentando entrar em contato para falar o
pessoal falava assim ah não ainda tá
muito assim não sei se ela vai ficar
ainda tá muito cismada alguma coisa
assim tu ver porque cismada com que o
pessoal quando vai conversar é só
querendo furar a pessoa me sentir
envergonhada que eu tomei conhecimento
geral mesmo de tudo depois de dez dias
que eu sair do confinamento e assim que
eu sair da casa no dia seguinte
a equipe me acompanhando para gravar meu
leque Então nem deu para similar
primeiro prato primeiro para depois ir
para outro trabalho ela já tava eu tava
ainda mancada na naquela casca da
soberba para me sentir menos a quadrada
então não tinha entendido muito bem Eu
sabia que eu havia errado dentro da casa
mas eu não entendia Quais foram os
pontos mais críticos mas no longo desses
dez direito foi assistindo porque ainda
minha equipe minha família me privada
onde assistir de ter noção de tudo
porque eu fiquei muito abalada com a
repercussão poderia ser muita informação
de uma vez só fazendo aos poucos Então
demorou muito depois de um mês ainda
assim eu fui foi caindo a ficha ainda a
hoje por exemplo já já teve outras cenas
que eu ainda não tinha visto ainda tem ó
o quê Porque tem que ter tipo um tempo
hábil para ver as coisas né porque tipo
foram muitos
Oi passa lá dentro né foram E aí eu
reprovo Obviamente as minhas atitudes
mas foi complicado não tem um momento de
descanso assim sair assimila então ter
uma equipe gravando a sua vida seu dia a
dia depois de confinamento depois de
você ter sido a mais odiada do Brasil e
às vezes você pensa que ter um papo
sincero com a pessoa e aí monte de gente
aqui filmando o que quer né porque é uma
hora para aí depois começa a hora as
pessoas escolhendo um momento da tua
vida que que são vendido isso né comecei
a me sentir uma coisa foi como se eu
fosse uma coisa cada um falar alguma
coisa na internet cada um tinha um
diagnóstico sobre a minha eu não assisti
o programa porque eu não sou assim eu
não assisto muito televisão geral assim
o reality em geral eu não assisto muito
que eu acho que quando a pessoa vai
torcer não tem que torcer Du quero
torcer vai brincar brincadeira inteira
Então vamos brincar Então vamos brincar
e e
a pessoa que eu durmo horário trocado
então eu perco às vezes tô querendo
saber quem vai sair amanhã perco a
iluminação Então para mim eu já vejo que
é um caso perdido eu não assisto as
coisas só que o Twitter tem que ser pelo
coo da gente as coisas que a gente não
tá nem aí querendo ver um monte de gente
um programa um sucesso né muita gente
assistir o programa e um monte de gente
falando todas as suas opiniões e todas
as paradas e tudo mais e aí eu teve um
episódio do que a galera falava de
xenofobia né Então nesse dia do episódio
como qualquer uma pessoa entrar no
Twitter vi um vídeo lá cortar um
pedacinho dizendo ela disse isso e fez
isso aí papá aí eu olhei o vídeo EA
legenda é está fiquei zangada com a
Carol fui lá no Instagram Carol daí eu
falo na cara porque eu me dou muito por
coisa de de Nordeste assim sabe falando
qualquer coisa azinho eu já me dou muito
assim entendeu Aí aí os dias foram
passando né entrando mais e eu vendo o
pessoal não sei que quando sair vai
pegar na pedra quando sair vou pegar de
pau
e para fazer isso quando sair vai eu eu
comecei a pensar assim como ser humano
normal assim um pouquinho parar e pensar
10 segundos antes de entrar na onda da
galera tá ligado eu parei um pouquinho
falei assim cara se é real a história de
fé que é real a história de energia
nessa é real a história de o que a gente
deseja a gente atrai que o pessoal fala
você é o que você sente você é o que
você pensa né assim então cara se for
verdade isso tudo isso que eu tô vendo
Twitter aqui agora galera odiando tipo o
Brasil um se um menino para o dia uma
pessoa só foi essa pessoa vai sair de lá
com o outro braço na barriga vai vai vai
botar uma coisa assim diferente um uma
gosma vai sair de dentro porque [ __ ] é
muito desejo ruim eu pensava assim não
tô não eu não vou participar dessa
parada tá ligado vou dizer aprovei a
atitude lá porque eu também como
qualquer pessoa entrei e vi um pedaço né
E aí depois eu fiquei
Tô vendo que tava todo mundo entrando
numa consciência de odiar uma pessoa de
coletivo mod mesmo direcionado aí eu
comecei a achar que isso não é muito não
é bom e nem um cenário e nem um cenário
isso é legal a gente vê que a atitude
dessas pessoas acabam sendo piores do
que a minha dentro da casa e que elas
estejam tão doentes quanto eu até mais
é porque ali naquele momento eu tava
amarga eu tava cheia de questões
pessoais minhas e ninguém tem culpa do
Estado quando tu entrou que eu tava bem
eu acho que não porque há dois anos eu
já tava sentindo uma certa aflição e uma
vontade de não fazer nada eu acho que
isso aí é sabe o que nada sou psicólogo
não sei não mas assim eu também já
passei tantas questões na minha cabeça
que tanta gente fala para mim sim ou não
só mas você tem isso eu tenho aquilo
você o Brasil ama você as pessoas gostam
de você aí eu faço em sim pô mas pode
não gostar qualquer dia delícia tá
ligado pode não gostar porque todo mundo
é gostado um tempo tá ligado entendeu
Tipo o todos os pilotos de avião são
muito bons e são muito [ __ ] mas tem uns
que fica triste jogo avião em outro
lugar [ __ ] tá
e ele é uma pessoa normal igual qualquer
pessoa então então tipo assim eu acho
que um pouco disse aí que você tava
passando a de entrar era a mesma coisa
que às vezes eu passo essa parada de
tipo é aqui então é isso aqui então tipo
assim então é eu cheguei aqui aí tipo eu
posso mandar em outras pessoas e eles
fazem umas coisas para mim eu pago eles
é assim então tá ligada Às vezes a gente
se altos a bota e às vezes o nosso
interior quer falar alguma coisa que a
gente não tá ouvindo e eu pude perceber
depois que eu sair do confinamento que
eu tava cheia de questões mal resolvidas
E aí o problema foi que tipo assim tu
foi para um lugar mais vigiada do Brasil
no momento das duas questões mais
resolvidas
e eu fui isso por minhas feridas camada
cinzas no programa Mais vigiada do
Brasil vamo tipo botar numa situação que
aconteceu lá dentro pega alguma situação
assim que aconteceu lá dentro tu sabe
que tinha um pé um pé assim de uma coisa
não resolveram na tua cabeça aqui fora
assim por exemplo tem a questão da minha
mania de organização e quando eu tava
ali na casa e eu notei que isso ia ser
um problema porque as coisas não ficava
organizado não ficava organizadas E aí
eu pensei na os eu acho que vou me
irritar com isso aí tinha uma outra
questão que me sentir insegura porque
ali naquele momento na minha cabeça eu
pensava tô no jogo Eu preciso jogar aqui
a gente precisa arquitetar relações
Então você fala com uma pessoa essa
pessoa te falo uma coisa você entende
outra você passa outra isso foi visível
com Tom
e os participantes E aí eu ficava numa
situação que eu me senti a pirada sabe
pirata paranoia mesmo na cabeça com tudo
inclusive com a minha participação ali
dentro e aí voltou começa também a ficar
porque tem o fator isolamento né que a
galera não bota aqui fora é o fator
isolamento está fechado com a galera
entendeu uma coisa que eu percebi que
talvez uma leitura que seja até o seu
lado é horrorosa mas assim o quando o
Lucas saiu pegou as coisas dele saiu né
que era uma das coisas que também chegou
para mim eu não assisto mais uma das
coisas que lá no Twitter o dia inteiro a
galera falando a mesma coisa então quem
não viu de manhã nem meio-dia nem a
tarde vendo aí te assim é difícil você
não vê e aí você vem vários psiquiatras
dando opinião vários assim médico
complicadas vários laudos tá ligado
várias paradas teve um até um que eu fiz
eu falei assim gente
É eu sei que tem vários psiquiatra
psicólogo dando seus lados mas para mim
eu vi que um cara bebeu se passando
Lembrei de falar umas bostas isso na
vida real no outro dia você dá um caldo
de ovo para a pessoa tá ligado e fala
Opa meu irmão ele ontem foi você deu um
show tá ligado tá ligado E aí lá dentro
Eu falei assim mas parece que a galera
não não não tá afim já colheu bebo tá
ligado Tipo assim parece que a situação
era para ser uma situação típica de uma
sociedade qualquer entendeu pessoas que
bebem passam do limite isso acontece né
Tipo você não odeia uns tio seu porque
eles ficam bebo no final do ano é da
normal eles sempre ficam várias entendeu
então tipo assim quando eu vi o que
aconteceu falou era para alguém dar de
manhã selada no café para ele falou
assim tá melhor porque [ __ ] tu ficou
very crazy ontem tu não acho que o cara
foi legal nas atitudes do cara também
mas tipo ele tava muito louco entendeu
então tipo assim uma vida normal na vida
real todo mundo ia falar Tipo Diogo
ontem
um pouquinho só que todo mundo é então
aí vem o fator o jogo que você disse tem
que jogar né então tipo qual a rir e
sabe o que eu senti naquele momento que
tipo assim aquilo ali era como se fosse
uma mini sociedade né não tinha uma
pessoa que mandava uma pessoa que uma
pessoa que era mais tranquilo uma pessoa
que era mais da do sertanejo né que a
galera vai marcar um ladinho assim você
vai vendo que as coisas vão tomando cada
um seu ladinho assim sabe E aí quando
quando o Lucas saiu
e eu vi como se nessa mini sociedade ele
tivesse tipo se suicidado tá porque as
pessoas que ficam dentro não sabem o que
aconteceu depois que ele passou por
Depois da porta entendeu e acaba que
tipo por uns dias você realmente é você
ver que a galera fica um pouco de luto
por um tempo e aí depois é esquecido
tipo como qualquer sociedade tá ligado
só que ele era um mini sociedade zinha
de pessoas pequenas entendeu as vezes eu
vejo no meu bairro também são melhor
duas vezes eu sei quem é o confusão
confusão do meu bairro eu sei quem é eu
sei quem é o menino que passa correndo
aqui sempre faz um negócio entendeu eu
tenho é uma mina e sociedade nha naquele
momento eu vim como tipo assim [ __ ]
cara saiu Saiu alguém tinha que ter
conversado um pouquinho comendo mais
então muito faltou espírito
É verdade faltou caridade empatia ali
sabe foi um bateu no EGO de todo quando
chegou ali aí eu parei de parei de de
consumir no twitter também tipo eu
peguei a palavra botei ali e tirei um
pouco eu já tava me sentindo meio
estranho sabe se sentir um pouco
estranho assim quando você ver se acorda
aí tá todo mundo falando porque [ __ ] aí
ontem teve a festa e aí Vitor disse isso
eu não sei quem Papai acorda de manhã tá
todo mundo dizendo a Vitor falou isso
para pouca e isso isso isso aí fica todo
mundo falando mesma coisa a mesma coisa
eu falei assim não pera aí eu vou o cara
saiu ontem eu
eu vou dar um time desse negócio aqui
assim as coisas lá dentro elas ficam
todas diferentes então você acha que é
uma coisa é outra não tem muito como e
não tem muito o que fazer nos e ficado
numa conspirar Dinha né Será que Fulano
tá o jogo aqui para você não é isso é
uma coisa muito curiosa porque as
pessoas aqui foram ficam julgando porque
fulana falou de ciclano lá dentro mas o
game é esse Você precisa arquitetar as
relações ela não dá para você não falar
de voto porque tipo enquanto você tá Se
você tipo curtir a casa tem outra pessoa
que está articulando né gente você
precisa articulando também fica naquela
insegurança ela Poxa mais como é que tá
ali aquela pessoa tá do meu lado é meu
aliado ou não é então tem pessoas lá
dentro que ficam muito carente tendo só
que ficam mais a ácidas amargas que foi
no caso tem pessoas que ficam mais dor
minhocas do viu Alumina quando tu saiu
vi
A Camila é como é dentro fora ou ela
também se vê se viu diferença em dia
diferente foi uma a gente come telefone
Conversando a gente tá vendo um
experimento experimento científico você
tem que ser estudado ela é leve ela é
doce e ali também ela teve gatilhos né
que tiveram válvulas ali que acabou
despertando umas coisas nela assim como
ele também mas o meu estado de
agressividade lá dentro não Ninguém tem
culpa sabe eu reconheço isso mas eu já
entrei em casa com pouco eu entendo
porque por exemplo assim Carol sendo bem
sincero tipo já teve uma situação no
Ceará que que houve como se fosse tipo
um campo de concentração tá ligado onde
as pessoas mandavam os pobres Para
Morrer tipo estava morrendo nas ruas
falando tira daqui porque acho que fica
feia ela chegar para ela tomar narro
Então bora Para Morrer pular eu morrer
tipo 200 mil cearenses tá ligado
O Nordestino aqui para São Paulo os
imigrantes e aí eles construíam tudo que
todo mundo anda toda calçada todo prédio
antigo aqui é de emigrante Então cara
chega para mim não fala alguma coisa de
Nordeste Nordestino eu fico possesso
fico muito puto tá ligado eu saio de mim
um pouco então eu tava até falando com
os amigos meu assim cara se se o meu
povo sofresse todo e tudo aquilo que o
povo da Carol sofrer eu ia andar sem por
cento full pistola todo tempo toda hora
Bom dia a [ __ ] Bom dia o [ __ ] era
toda hora Sim entendeu então tipo assim
quando você me fala de gatilho a
primeira coisa que me vem na minha
cabeça é alguém fala alguma coisa e
Nordeste na hora assim eu já venho aqui
sabe teve um cara também me convidou
para o podcast aí uma parada tudo mais e
um dia desse ele falava que não falou
que São Paulo sustentável no nordeste
ele tipo não quis saber nem um pingo do
contexto uma desse caixa
e o Paulo de que ele Vista financeiro
fiquei tão processo dessa parada que eu
consigo entender tipo uma hora que você
tem um gatilho e ainda mais quem tem
vários gatilho né porque são vários
gatinhos Sim vários assim quando quando
o pessoal falava e a Karol com K em tava
no lugar tava conversando tal e agora no
carrinho aí eu falava cara tá lá né tá
tá lá no Big Brother saiu né brigada ela
saiu ainda não não tá lá não sei que
tudo mais aí eu aí eu falei assim mais
cara
a ver tipo como Como tudo tem história
tudo tem contexto a
e eu por exemplo é só um cara que eu
fico que eu fui crente 10 anos 10 anos
da minha vida foi evangélico igreja tá
um bolo todinho biblinha tá tá na igreja
lá lonjão igual aqueles Sabe aqueles que
a gente anda focado Você viu o crente lá
e vai o cliente rápido ligeiro Bubu
andando com minha calça social e tal e
ele era crente dez anos sabe né Eu segui
as coisas assim direitinho mesmo tudo
que falava o pastor vizinhos disseram
que você não viu que o pastor disse
rapaz misericórdia misericórdia era
irmão de Misericórdia irmão entendeu
falava meu Deus eu era assim eu era uma
pessoa desse jeito aí e aí eu vi eu
tinha um preconceito homossexual tem
noção não tinha um maior para conselho
de um maior preconceito eu tinha um
preconceito que eu não gostava de falar
sobre culta tem noção
Ah e não tem nem a ver uma coisa com a
outra você não pode ligar
homossexualidade ayako não tem a ver uma
coisa com a outra deu hoje eu tenho essa
noção antigamente a minha nossa era tão
ridícula sim que eu eu não queria
conversar sobre o negócio que pudesse
lembrar o que tem a ver uma coisa com a
outra entendeu E aí eu chego um tempo da
minha vida que descanse assim eu tive
que fazer a cirurgia no cuccaro ó vida
me trouxe até eu tenho que abrir minhas
pernas dentro de um lugar com várias
pessoas e eu dormi né as pessoas
chegando para me operar eu com as perna
aberta aqui falando meu Deus lá
enfermeira entrando várias enfermeira e
eu apagando eu não eo coelhinho usam né
E aí eu piro enfeite do mudo a evolução
do concessão pedaço da minha história e
são a parte do meu corpo então tipo
quando alguém chegar para mim falar
assim ó você não sabe o que eu passei na
você não sabe o que que o espaço nessa
ver que que o ônibus passou na vida tudo
meu amigo tudo entendeu então tipo assim
quando o pessoal te dá tava querendo
tiver tornar e me fazer o que queria
fazer que tava dizendo que queria fazer
aí quando sair eu vou fazer isso vou
fazer aquilo dentro de mim eu só
esperava alguém dizer alguém tem um
pouquinho de compaixão perto de mim
primeiro pelos é a primeira pessoa logo
eu comecei a achar estranho que em todo
lugar fala assim Gente peraí não parar
com essa Vamos parar com essa conversa
não eu ficava esperando alguém fazer que
falar e quando alguém falava assim tipo
assim ó a cara mas não é bom falar nada
dela porque ninguém sabe o que ela
passou não falar ninguém sabe dela
passada de mim fazer assim ninguém sabe
o que ela passou
e ela passou tudo mano tudo é muita
coisa meu amigo é muita coisa na vida de
uma pessoa se essa aqui foi história do
meu corpo e mudou tanto tudo que mudou
imagina um a história de uma pessoa
imagine a estrada da pessoa que nem tu
assim é ruim ficar é ruim quando a gente
percebe que nossas falhas acabam criando
um rótulo e a gente é reduzido a a um
capítulo desse livro eu falo que eu sou
um livro somos é como se fosse nos
livros né então a gente não tem como
reduzir resumir a história de um livro
vendo só um capítulo não se tem que
entender o que tem antes daquele
capítulo que vem depois exatamente eu eu
super reconheço meus erros Óbvio Mas eu
também estou naquele processo de não me
detestar
e não me reprovar eu não posso ser a
pessoa que vai fazer isso que ficou
pensando em tudo isso quando eu só eu
fico eu fiquei fiquei muito triste
sorriso só que é eu fiquei aí vendo uma
galera fazendo diagnóstico saber eu
falando com o especialista perguntando
eu só isso que estamos falando chamaram
de psicopata sociopata narcisista
primeiro ver se eu tiver algum próximo
me diga não ele é eu fiquei assim eu
falei meu Deus mas por que que eu fiquei
desse jeito nessa cena não me reconheço
nessa já me reconheço que tenho agora se
de primeiro que para chegar onde cheguei
não foi fácil Óbvio isso é até clichê
mas é a história de muita gente a nossa
história então eu precisei ter pulso
mais firme algumas se eu lhe perguntar o
que que você passou só de tudo tudo tudo
só não tá isso pronto É isso aí é só
faltava Isso aí Isso aqui é às vezes
esse é um medo que eu tenho é
e não não de estragar tudo não tenho
medo de estragar tudo tá ligado mas por
exemplo não sou ser humano normal né
você um ser humano normal apesar da
pessoa da Galera achar que quando a
gente entra no carro alguma coisa irada
dentro acontece não acontece nada tipo
motorista sai andando a gente fica
mexendo no celular e E aí alguém fala
Oi e aí sei lá e manda um GIF engraçado
igual uma pessoa normal entendeu então
então eu penso tipo assim quando eu via
Quando eu via quando você tava agindo
daquele jeito eu ficava assim cara às
vezes eu tenho medo de eu estar desse
jeito aí e não não tá me ligando também
porque ela só não tá se ligando eu sei
que ela não é assim já conversei com ela
já vi ela várias vezes ela não é desse
jeito aí não mas assim
e ela não tá se ligando na hora não tá
se ligando e aí e aí eu pensava assim às
vezes eu ficava assim [ __ ] Será que
eu tô sendo uma pessoa legal tô de boa
eu tô tipo viajando achando que eu tô
arrasando na ligado tem vai medir el tu
ver aquela parte aqui para falar que tu
fala se não gostou me bota no paredão
que que tu acha além de Engraçado que
ela tão vendo ó
E é sério eu ficava assim aí quando eu
vi que esse momento virou meme Eu não
entendi nada e ainda tinha pessoas
falando que foi uma jogada de marketing
porque tudo as pessoas acham que eu tô
pagando para fazerem ou tem algum ponto
no meu ouvido essa bateria estavam que
eu sou rodada na sua cabeça e ela chegou
ao ponto que assim falei gente tô sem
moral só não acreditam em mim por causa
de um erro Eles não conseguem enxergar
mais nada do que a genuína em mim Eles
não conseguem acreditar em nada ou
porque preferem o dia' continuar
mediando porque a confortável para
aliviar a frustração deles mesmos ou
porque não conseguem entender que as um
ser humano que eu tenho minhas camadas e
uma das minhas camadas foram expostas no
reality show mas se colocar uma câmera
na casa de todo mundo todo mundo vai ter
um momento de cancelamento acho que é
mais a segunda opção
Quem sabe a gente se uma pessoa normal
mesmo e é isso que eu tava falando tipo
eu sou uma pessoa normal ela fala assim
ah mas o povo as pessoas gosta de você
falar e deixou deixou atropelar um
cachorro sem querer Deixa eu fazer um
alguma coisa que um ser humano normal
faz do tipo sei lá tô aqui e aconteceu
uma eventualidade é uma parada tá ligado
qualquer coisa e aí tudo pode mudar todo
o cenário pode mudar toda a realidade
pode mudar tudo que você teve várias
ideias passou várias noites pensando e
tentando dar sua cara ao projeto um
negócio né porque a gente tá sempre
assim não é bota tudo por água abaixo
você fala meu Deus um surto emocional
desequilíbrio emocional e comportamental
né que eu tive ali eu falei caramba não
que eu não tenho aquele temperamento Não
precisei ser daquele jeito aqui fora mas
não com aquela intensidade no momento
que desnecessário por exemplo ali não
precisava não precisava sabe eu
reconheço que não precisava
eu reconheço também que faz parte de mim
aquilo ali também faz parte da minha
camada Então eu preciso tratar essa
parte para conseguir lidar com
frustrações eu nunca tinha parado para
pensar ele para não mas acontece é
porque tipo você quando tá lindo uma
situação nacional e aí você fica tipo
meio que todo mundo meio que diz seca
todo ato seu tá ligado toda fala e tudo
a galera meio que dá uma secadinha que
isso acontecesse com qualquer pessoa na
rua não se a gente ia ver muito mais
coisa talvez ainda que não chegou o
momento que é nas redes as pessoas fazer
montagem com rosto de outros
participantes quando eles tinham
atitudes humanas como ciúmes fazer
intriguinha tirar satisfação então
parecia que todas essas atitudes foi fui
eu que inventei é como se ninguém mais
se o ciúmes nunca ninguém teve ciúmes a
Carol inventou o ciumes Carol inventou a
disse
é tão dentro de um jogo de um Reality é
disso que a gente sobrevive lá dentro
senão você pode ir para o paredão se não
você pode perder uma prova Tem várias
coisas várias questões não dá para
misturar com que tá aqui fora então
assim eu o que se o que se planta se
colhe No meu caso eu acho que a colheita
está sendo muito grande perto do que Eu
Plantei sabe então vem aquele sentimento
de sim eu reconheço que errei e ao mesmo
tempo de Poxa mas Precisava tudo isso
para possam ser muito grande e só comigo
sabe não que eu não não desejo isso que
eu passei Tô passando para ninguém mas
eu acho que vale a reflexão nem eu
e quando eu quando eu assim quando eu
tenho um período que eu fico ruim mal
esse momento é um momento que eu fico
todo tempo pensando assim eu queria eu
queria lembrar de como é quando você tá
feliz o que lembrar de como é que você
tá feliz sabia fica naquele coisa quando
eu tô assim bem bed assim não consigo
sair do fundo do poço entendeu Aí eu
penso assim como é que a pessoa consegue
desejar isso para alguém quando você tá
muito mal você sabe a sensação de estar
Mal sabe ela corporal né não é só mental
e corporal Assim você fica meio você
fica meio assim sabe aquela cozinha você
fica lembrando é para dentro de você
fica meio homem da Sky para difícil é e
você mesmo assim sabe se essa é a
sensação imprensa assim pra dentro e aí
Nossa eu não quero não que as pessoas
paciências então não entrei
e na hora da galera não entrei na
brincadeira porque a maioria dessas
pessoas que eu vi é porque todo mundo
que Eu segui tava assistindo e tava
comentando todo mundo sem exceção todas
as pessoas que esse dia tava comentando
e tava lá metendo o pau falando normal e
tudo mais e tudo mais e as mesmas
pessoas que falam de empatia empatia e
foi aí que eu comecei a pegar a Carol se
eu te falando e Sinceridade um pouquinho
de novo dessa palavra empatia porque
assim é uma palavra até muito bonita me
lembra uma cor de sangue empatia né uma
Coelho de alguma coisa de doação né sei
lá me lembro é que eu gosto de associar
as palavras algumas tipo tem falar caixa
bonita eu acho que é Natália eu acho
lindo mas o que eu instalei o Natal faz
é feita é o mais a palavra esta
comentário net Nossa gostosinho queria
muito ruim ter um grande excitá-lo
Natália do Brasil eu queria muito cedo
mas só que o estelionatário rouba cartão
dos outros aí eu não quero mais ser
entendeu mas a
a palavra legal aí a palavra empatia nós
é uma palavra até legal até bonita só
que tipo assim hoje em dia eu não sei o
que que é que a galera Pega umas
palavras joga na roda e passa um tempo a
palavra não tem sentido mais ela não ela
é só uma palavra mesmo igual tipo mesa
cadeira ela tem gente comenta é eu vejo
pessoas comentando vamos ter mais
empatia com a Carol aí outra pessoa
comenta vamos ter mais empatia com ela
que não teve empatia Então qual é o
papel da empatia ele é para quem tem e
quem não tem como é que a gente lida com
o momento uma situação que a pessoa está
num estado de nervo onde a empatia falta
você ignora essa pessoa ou você contagia
ela com a empatia E aí é mais uma pessoa
para entender a empatia então às vezes a
empatia tá julgando a empatia corrente
foi no shopping empatia é a corrente da
empatia e o que que é empatia empatia é
você se colocar no
um lugar
uma das pessoas da situação não de uma
pessoa da situação entendeu que você não
bota só de uma pessoa que toda a
situação é que é uma situação de
conversa de conflito tem mais gente né
Você não pode ter empatia por uma pessoa
escolher quem a pessoa que tem empatia e
ter você tem que ter empatia pelo filho
da Carol pela mãe obrigado Lucas
Penteado também por ele pelos amigos
dele exato tudo entendeu tá ligado então
tipo assim agora tem um patia com o
público que me odeia isso você tem
entendeu porque o público onde que ele
odeia você já não tá levando uma com eu
odeio eles vocês levando diálogo porque
eu entendo porque eles estão assim é a
empatia é se vocês colocaram lá eu
entendo que eu eu protagonizei cenas ali
é totalmente desgostosos sabe o que
causa aflição então eu entendo a raiva
deles por mim e a gente que tá nessa
posição de figura pública a gente não
pode errar isso é é torturante também
para gente porque é o tempo inteiro
sendo perfeito ou criando uma vida dupla
então eu tenho a vida mais elevada EA
vida artista e ali É como se eu tivesse
misturado apagado com tudo entendeu É
como se eu tivesse me jogado fora me
abandonado então comecei a avaliar isso
eu tô com problema de Alto amor qual é o
problema porque eu entrei no reality e
porque eu dessa forma esquecendo os meus
princípios meu respeito o respeito pelo
próximo e quando a gente trata as
pessoas assim é porque a gente tá sem
sem amor para si mesmo né então quando a
gente não se ama a gente trata outro lá
na Carol então tipo como se fosse para
ti uma outra pessoa não Karol Conká Sou
Eu também mas é um alter-ego é uma coisa
mais firme mais poderosa é como se ela
não deixasse que a Carole
o tempo do igual dos artistas que é
diferente por Caroline Tomaz
a tomar novo não não Caroline Tomaz II
Eu tô tomando tô tomando gente
o teste de nós também bota no paredão
bota no paredão da carreira bem bonita
lá fora entendeu eu falo gente e o povo
Cadê a carreira dela
E ai que horror eu não posso me odiar eu
me perdoo eu me perdoo mas qualquer
coisa me bota na tua oração qualquer
coisa faz uma oração que eu tinha uma
carreira bem bonita aqui fora
E ai meu Deus eu tô indo mais do que eu
assistir Jojo stand amor minha língua
não é mais um chicote hoje em dia hoje
já já tá diferente né é cortei né já tá
com gírias nordestinas Agora sim eu tô
no processo que eu tenho que entender o
deboche quando tu quando tu saiu aí tu
ficou tipo se tu ficou assim vendo e aí
tu ficava dizendo assim tipo
e aqui aqui eu entendo que foi isso era
tipo assim tinha cenas que eu falava
porque eu fiz isso porque hoje dessa
forma não me reconheço e tem cenas que
eu olho e falo tá que eu me reconheço
então que tem que brincar e agora não
não entendeu sim tem essas partes também
juntou com uma hora que eu falei uma
merda aí tá parecendo que eu tô na
verdade eu deixei dessa fã então tem
cena que realmente eu me passei tem
outras que não é naquele Tom que foi
replicado nas redes sociais eu sempre
fui muito brincalhona Debochada de falar
fazendo assim sempre brinquei com isso
mas não tão leve de brincadeira e lá
dentro também eu eu me sentia asfixiada
pelos meus próprios pensamentos então
aqui fora as pessoas começaram a brincar
algumas atitudes que eu tinha dentro da
casa com vídeos antigos onde eu falava
de filmes favoritos do momento
e eu falei sobre o fragmentado não
desses vídeos de nos sei lá quanto tempo
atrás e aí essas Olha Ela é psicopata é
fragmentar até as personalidades aí eu
vi um vídeo que eu tô no quarto com
outro participante e eu começo a falar
desse jeito aqui e eu fico suando
falando gente não sei o quê e aí
Associação Nossa Senhora ela é outra
pessoa falei e e acontece que as pessoas
esquecem que eu só artista e artista
toda artista Tem Uma Mente criativa e eu
gosto muito de brincar e de fazer
personagens isso não tá ligado Júlio
sabe tipo eu gosto de fazer tipo eu tô
sem saco né É então
bom então então eu faço eu faço assim
tipo ah tá demorando aqui a gravar O
negócio dá para pagar meu pai
a mandioca
E aí como é que você tá num reality eu
tô fazendo analisar para falar que você
tem múltiplas personalidades no meu caso
não é isso está Tô vendo que você queria
né verdade a gente tem eu a Diana trazer
o laudo falar galera tá aqui mas não é
só na verdade são duas somos oito Eu
Diana sim jaca jaca ela tem esse dois
lados que é o lado melancólico lado mais
um e o lado mais sarcástico e debochado
então eu tiro o sal de mim mesmo eu já
tô no nível que assim já consigo tirar
onda com a minha cara para nós mas é uma
ridícula entrou lá dentro se achando
toda cagada no rolê achando que tá
vazando aí vai querida eu falo comigo
mesmo eu falo querida eu fiquei muito
brava quando eu viu aí não sei o quê na
na foi meu Deus ele tem um outro ver ter
que eu ficava disco
Me desculpe por ser depois chato e é o
Sempre falei assim desse jeito brincando
com as minhas amigas sabe tirando uma
onda e ali parece que eu sou daquele
jeito mas também sou no meu o meu estado
de humor não quer dizer que não seja um
pouquinho às vezes brincando no estado
de humor é uma coisa que tá ali e outra
sou uma mulher que já tá um bom tempo
fazendo shows e trabalhando com TV
imagem público então assim não querem
que eu diga que eu tenho uma carreira ou
que eu sou poderosa é como se a gente
não pudesse falar sobre isso É como se
eu não pudesse achar isso sabe então só
várias questões que eu fui levantando
analisando os vídeos de várias erros
meus e vários erros do público Então se
resolver Porque tipo quem quem falou de
você hoje tá nem aí eles não estão
falando se você vai então as pessoas
elas querem que eu continue
se continuar me batendo então bateram
tão forte em mim justamente para você
Karol Conká ai poderosa encheu a boca
para dizer que ter uma carreira bem
bonita Então vamos acabar com ela e aí
quando bate bate bate tá lá no chão
agora levanta vai vida que segue empatia
vem cá vou te acolher e depois de te
bater um monte eu te acolher para poder
usar #empatia dizer que eu estava aqui e
aí eu vou te bater de novo em fique
forte que é para te bater então tem esse
universo sádico eu reconheço também
pitadas de sadismo no meu comportamento
dentro da casa e está muito ligado em
segurança tá muito ligado à falta de
Alto amor então será que esse povo que
tá me odiando e faz questão de mediar
não também não tá com uma questão mal
resolvida no espelhada né Acontece muito
isso também a galera espelho em você sim
atitudes que ela quer que você tenha é
só que você é você e aí às vezes você
tem umas atitudes que a pessoa não teria
porque você não
se você é você mesmo entendeu então às
vezes a pessoa espelho em você a bondade
que elas pensam que tem aquelas vezes
elas acham que elas são muito
benevolente as Madre Teresa E aí elas
vão lá na Carol escalões papá é tem que
ver que tudo tem dois lados e e o lance
da do acolhimento da empatia ele tá
ligado ao sentimento a atitude de
caridade né que as pessoas confundem
qualidade só como você dá uma esmola de
alguma coisa está muito ligado a
paciência também é você entender o
processo do outro mas eu fiz eu já
levantei essa questão assim também perto
de roda de amigo a galera não tá nem aí
para isso não não já parei para prestar
atenção já leva um tecido tipo gente mas
assim Jesus a galera agora vai vir você
vem gente mas a gente a gente diz fé em
Deus Cristo aí tipo não julgue é tipo
não vamos tipo
e agora hora é agora hora de usar né
quando é que você quer usar é depois
quando uma pessoa erra você vai apunhala
Ela até ela cometer outros erros até
consigo mesmo de tristeza ou contagiar
ela com um real Espírito de Deus que é o
amor o respeito e ter mais uma pessoa
para espalhar essa ideia não menos uma
por isso que eu sou contra o
cancelamento Eu nunca fiz parte dessa
dessa corrente de cancelamento nunca
levei a sério isso porque eu acho que é
uma coisa muito séria as pessoas que
desejam anular a outra pessoa elas são
pessoas que já se anularam a muito tempo
e anularam a possibilidade de ser
empático CD espalhar o verdadeiro amor
então assim para mim no meu caso eu
ainda estou um pouco Abatida a balada
com as coisas que passaram para muita
gente foi só um um surto coletivo né
participação no reality para muita gente
acha que eu sou uma louca que faço
Oi para o está inventando vários
personagens e para as pessoas elas
conseguem entender que eu cometi esse
deslize comportamental emocional e eu tô
disposta a me tornar uma pessoa melhor
mais como tratando essas camadas então
convido as pessoas que estão com ódio
dentro do coração assim assim enxergar
em também e se reconhecerem os meus
erros porque eu sou ser humana Então
vamos todo mundo se tratar entendeu a
Carol vai se tratar assim eu vou mas
vocês também vão porque todo mundo
precisa né a conta que ela está dando a
marina que subir quanto que ela tava
falando uma coisa que tu não sabia nem
que hora que ela tava dizendo porque
tipo em momentos específicos que as
pessoas lembram que eu acho que aumento
parecido com Ontem quando eu fui gravar
o programa da Ana Maria foi já no dia
seguinte que eu sair do confinamento e
eu tinha dormido só 40 minutos cochilada
Então tava ali antes de dormir era o que
conversando toda hora com a minha mãe
minha mãe muito preocupada perguntando
se eu tava bem e eu não fui eu
e ela falou que eu tava estado de choque
porque eu não apresentava falava eu
falava não tudo bem só que eu não tava
tendo acesso às redes então eu não eu
não consegui eu estava me segurando
assim né E aí eu já tava com vergonha de
tá ali no programa e tentando manter a
simpatia o respeito ali pelo programa de
falar com Ana Maria então não dava para
chegar ao tipo ah mestre puxando sabe e
ainda tava tentando entender o que tava
acontecendo E aí ela comentou sobre
xenofobia
e sobre o sotaque da Juliet na hora eu
fiquei tentando assim lá do que que ela
estava falando qual foi esse momento e
eu só pensava não se justifique Carol
que isso tudo vai piorar E aí eu falo
tava sentindo que o negócio tava maior
do que o Agora é eu falei meu Deus como
é que eu vou falar não eu não sou
xenofóbica quando no momento as pessoas
querem mais aqui você se exploda
qualquer coisa que eu falasse ali
ninguém a da razão que eu só fico tensa
e eu faço isso de tensa Tipo o que
aconteceu eu falo não eu não tenho
problema consultar que da Juliet e eu
tentando assim segurar o choro mantendo
um falando caramba que que aconteceu que
ela dentro tá rolando uma vidinha né que
tá acontecendo assim então ninguém tá
muito se ligando em câmera que tipo
assim aí esse momento que acabou de
acontecer
tu tá ligado que ninguém pensa nisso né
É mais ou menos de Por que acontece
comigo no alguém chega come gosta de um
vídeo muito antigo tenho tipo 400 vídeos
no canal cara gosta do vídeo tipo número
82 aí ele gosta de uma frase que eu
falei no vídeo ele chega para mim fala e
aí eu entro o teu avô e esse esse aquilo
aí eu fico
o quê Qual foi Ai não é aquele vídeo tem
um momento gravado que te para galera
que tá aqui fora tá vendo E analisando
esse negócio assim tipo Olha a bolsa ali
tá aberta na Fulano tá dormindo tá
escutando a outra tá se maquiando tá
escutando ali o negócio Olha tá todo
mundo vendo E vocês estão conversando
normal como duas pessoas assim depois eu
entendi depois eu falei nossa eu fui
infeliz na minha colocação na hora que
eu fui falar da minha cidade para não
ter que usar uma palavra como reservado
na hora eu usei outra palavra educado e
isso Acabou ferindo muitos nordestinos
mas não saiu nenhum momento da minha
boca que eu não tenho respeito por
nordestina pelo nordeste ou que eu acho
que não é um povo educado o que eu falei
foi que eu no meu caso era mais fresca
para não ter que usar essa palavra falar
reservado ou fresca eu acabei falando
uma outra fui feliz na minha colocação
mas nem um momento eu tava com isso por
isso eu não em
e na hora que não ele falava porque eu
não tive essa intenção enquanto falava
das outras situações com outros
participantes eu entendia porque eu me
vi na situação de fazer feio mas nessa
especificamente não fosse feito de
errado também que eu deixei de seguir
mas não mas eu entendo eu entendo assim
eu me dou muito Nordeste falou um Eu me
dou demais mas aqui também procurar nem
sabem disse o quê que foi que hora foi
com quem já foi lá Nossa eu fiquei
desesperada porque eu falava assim meu
Deus não foi isso e eu queria fazer
vídeo eu queria fazer uma live e eu
queria falar e eu nervosa eu chorava e
aí eu pensava meu Deus mas esse público
não tá vendo o povo que tá achando que é
isso é porque não não sabe da minha
história não sabe que Jamais seria isso
jamais tanto que as minhas músicas tem
muitos elementos nordestinos por conta
da minha avó que a baiana e eu sempre
quis a baiana
e como é que a minha vó fugiu para
Curitiba ela sofre a violência doméstica
foi Baiano alguma vez na vida é elevar
era muito linda então eu achava que o
tom da minha pele era um pouquinho mas
desbotado que dela por eu ter nascido em
Curitiba que faz muito frio isso quando
era criança e aí Eu sempre tive respeito
então eu fiquei chateada de verdade os
meus melhores shows foram no nordeste
disparado e assim sempre tive uma
conexão muito gostosa com público então
ele na hora isso me cortou assim coração
não sabia como reagir e tiveram vários
filhos tendo eu acho que tipo como o
cinto tipo Manaus tipo se alguém
inventasse alguma história minha de
Manaus e tipo Manaus é tipo dos lugares
que eu faço shows mais irados mais
legais e tal e você tenha necessidade de
querer se explicar é uma coisa que ele
não falou não mas aí por causa desse
Episódio começaram a inventar fake News
"minhas tipo a Carol falou mal de tal
lugar só que não tinha vídeo disso
porque eu não
Oi e aí meu amigo que é de BH chegou a
comentar se nossa tem "aqui que você
falando mal de BH que foi o primeiro
lugar que eu fui cantar que eu pisei
fora de Curitiba para fazer show e eu
tenho um carinho muito grande então eu
fiquei assim me sentindo essa galera que
é destruir de todos os lados tem de
todas as se as coisas fossem justas
mesmo não teria tomado essa proporção
que eu acho que assim a jogo fiz cagada
no jogo elimina ali acabou mas assim
apedrejar já estão fazendo Pior tão indo
muito além do que é da minha atitude lá
dentro situação de distúrbio emocional
então é complicado né mas eu sei que
Quem me conhece sabe que o rolé outro
mas agora eu vou ter que penar para
falar assim ó gente só de boa tem o meu
lado uma reta assim não é à toa que eu
comecei a cantar um rap então não vou
ficar falando isso Santa que eu não sou
entendeu mas eu não quero que tentei
maldade para ninguém não
eu não acredito na justiça divina isso
acredito e as coisas vão se acalmar Amém
não sabe o que que foi logo ver as
pessoas é achando graça em algumas
situações tão tinha a gente que chegava
falar assim olha que legal você é muito
famosa agora
e olha só favela não sei se acho legal
essa forma né dessa forma né olha que
legal tem mesmo e com a tua cara e eu
pude não não sei se acho que você legal
porque
vou começar a fazer mesmo de uma
situação de namorar comigo que eu gostei
foi o único que eu gostei mas eu achei
esse Engraçado que era era eu na era eu
na capa da Toddy E aí tinha assim olha
Todd trocou de boi foi [ __ ] essa que foi
não foi não essa eu falei não foram
foram incisivos a galera a galera que
figurou no mercado assim com a minha
cara e bateu a foto tá ligado Tipo vamos
lá engraçada ela vai bate a ela para
Face não pera aí galera vou mandar aqui
para ela acho muito engraçado assim
também eu ficava só chocada eu falava
porque porque eu tava um tempo afastado
das redes quando eu sair eu falei mas
É porque tem um revivendo um milhão e
nove novecentos assim aí tu foi para 800
e o [ __ ] a galera tá deixando de
seguir ela velho aí foi uns 700 vai
fazer senão a pera aí vai foi muito
porque a gente pega a gente quer dar um
tempo para maldade já prestou atenção
rapidarun pedra eu queria que você
perder se ele Clara para mexer no cem
mil da mamãe quando for 200 mais 200 a
gente já em gente aí começou passar tipo
assim do que eu tinha de teto para
maldade não eu peço para maldade Era Cem
Mil sair de novo sem nenhum eu não sei
como é que ficou um milhão é pouco ainda
quando eu saí porque eu passei Nossa
você e toda cagada Mas é porque tipo
meio que a engrenagem roda a engrenagem
roda ele desce aí você sai você vira o
nome falado engrenagem dar uma rodada
você volta um pouquinho de novo assim eu
entendo eu recebi muitas mensagens
legais assim Teve muitas diotti Óbvio
mas muitas mensagens bacanas assim sabe
que
eu acordava de manhã já com uma era uma
sensação de uma bola de House ou de gelo
no meio do peito ansiedade pura Eu
imagino assim porque essa sensação eu
acho que ela fica mais aparente ainda
Corolla fica mais aparente eu digo isso
pensando na situação que eu tive triste
muito triste também e quando você é pior
quando você dorme acorda e o problema
ainda existe ele existe ele pode
aumentar ele tá crescendo enquanto você
está acordando Tomando café ele tá
crescendo ele não pode mais coisas
dizendo mais negócio então assim
conseguir perceber que eu me perdi de
mim da minha essência do meu propósito
há muito tempo até uns dois anos por aí
que eu já tinha percebido que eu não
tava bem Tem um amigo meu que perguntou
para mim Carol fala que só para mim você
foi o personagem você quis fazer de
propósito falei o adoraria poder dizer
assim foi um personagem Aí sim coisa a
gente imagina
e foi arquitetado a gente eu e a minha
Assessoria Sim a gente queria sair com
na verdade para 99,99 mais anti-roubo
uma vez eu tive 17 isso mas é isso
obrigado Esse foi o meu imaginei ser
fantástica Léo Brasil Calma calma lá era
um personagem eu sou ficou aqui dentro
para causar isso nossa seria fantástico
se fosse isso mas não foi eu falei amigo
não dele mais que quem é aquela foi
aquela também sou eu é um pedaço meu que
tava aqui dentro e virou aquilo lá Deus
também ainda tô tentando entender se
gostou a tem gente que gostou né Opa tem
até perfil enaltecendo cada pedaço cada
movimento feio fétido que eu tenho feito
a pessoa assim d'Ávila d'Ávila mesmo
gosto da vilania coisas que é o meu
repúdio io de atitudes minhas
e a pessoa fala nossa que linda a pessoa
curtiu a versão que tu não curte é E aí
tem também pessoas que tá lá e que
maravilhosa ela que chegue bem linda
vestida de Malévola bem vilã da na cara
do Brasil Dá na cara de todo mundo e eu
assim não não eu tô Caída no Chão nesse
momento não era isso que vocês queriam
me ver Tombada daí eu dou uma tomada aí
não você não sabe no meu inbox porque eu
fico afastada das redes e teve uns dias
dois dias da semana que eu tinha acesso
assim eu consegui ver meu Deus pessoas
me mandando muitas mensagens lindas e
essas mesmas pessoas que me mandaram
oração e coração em cima de a mensagem
salvas de do início do programa elas me
detonando E aí no final as nossa me
perdoa eu fesporte do arco evolutivo da
pessoa isso de amor de hoje é se
reconstruiu é o que já te falou nada se
eu te ajudei muito na casa mas depois
e o óleo diminuiu que quando você chega
e o presencial é muito diferente o
presencial é outra coisa entendeu Tipo
assim quando quando ele tava te chamando
e aí tá tinha toda essa questão de pa é
porque vai ser um documentário aí tem
que esperar isso aqui não mas vamos e a
gente foi tentando se entender e tudo
mais eu eu fiquei nervoso um pouquinho
assim nossa eu não sei porque não sei
como você vai sentar aqui na minha
frente eu não sei se é depois de tipo
Você também devia pensar a mesma coisa
de mim de você não sei o que que ele vai
dia que que ele vai falar ele vai dizer
não é lá tem dia que que você que com a
mulher ser porque como eu já te
acompanho um tempo a gente foram poucas
vezes que a gente se viu ao vivo mas
teve uma existe uma conexão de energia
cabeça conexão que a gente alimenta
quando a gente não vai aparecer outro
lado entendeu tá ligado Tipo assim
e tem muitas pessoas que eu vou atrás
assim no às vezes na internet que eu
vejo um comportamento estranho da pessoa
um pouco três meses sem postar uma foto
assim uma pessoa que eu vi que era muito
ativo era muito feliz mas está assim eu
sempre que eu vejo eu vou atrás para
conversar das pessoas e geralmente essas
pessoas são as pessoas que são um pouco
rejeitado assim ela é uma galera que
tipo já tentou ser aceita aquela rodinha
não deu naquela não deu naquela não deu
naquela não deu virou lobo solitário e
não sabe ser só entendeu porque o meu
acho que o meu maior talvez eu mato na
vida é saber só
e Talvez seja isso que fez eu chegar
onde eu cheguei seja saber se é só Lobo
Solitário tá ligado vou trabalhar tenho
isso ela tá aqui conversando tá
trabalhando comigo nossa tá ótimo tô
curtindo legal fico aqui nossa tranquilo
mas sou assim ah não andar comigo Ah não
tá na mesma sintonia na mesma ideia eu
já vou por ali encontra outra galera e
assim eu vou nômade também mas que tava
com signo porque você é capricórnio que
nem eu porque assim eu sempre me senti
deslocada e a vontade onde eu estou e já
com aquela com a cabeça desapegada
porque eu sei que ir lá na frente talvez
eu não esteja aqui então eu vivo que eu
tenho que viver cria um laço e se não tá
se não bater mesma frequência dali para
frente eu vejo não vejo como um problema
simplesmente eu vejo como a não é para
ser assim tá tudo bem vou seguir também
tipo que é possível
não é possível que aconteça qualquer
coisa eu tô conversando com a pessoa e
tal aí aí beleza é sua amiga da pessoa e
Ok mas aí a ideia não tá batendo mais eu
sempre penso assim não ser perfeitamente
possível que ele não desse certo essa
amizade eu pensei eu pensei que você me
chamou por você já ter passado por uma
situação de aflição que a gente não
consegue expressar pelo lado artístico
das coisas gente tem a cabeça muito
frita criativa e por você ter entendido
o que aconteceu então é o primeiro
programa que eu venho desde quando eu
sair com o Lucas talvez foi a situação
que eu achei mais assim porque tipo acho
que acho que eu tenho a parada da
depressão sim e aí tipo assim você ficar
só e ninguém lhe entender um pouco
porque você fala uma ninguém na casa vai
lá tranho entendeu Tipo né daí ninguém
vai não sei o que foi isso que dá um eu
eu não falei meu Deus tudo bem eu tava
bem louca ali a fulana tava bem louca
mais não tinha ninguém 19 pessoas na
casa isso que eu fiquei questionando se
alguém tivesse conversado não na porta
tá ligado entende como eu falei como eu
comprei a situação acho que ninguém você
não precisa conversar com a pessoa
quando ela tá na beira do prédio diante
dela subir né é conversar tá ligada
conversar normal é tipo é aquele cara
que vocês bar na rua que o cara fala
assim você essa mulher que fica a rua
tal e aí você fala assim para eu tô
atrasada e sai andando sabe se você
soubesse um pouco da vida daquele rapaz
você teria dito assim Bom dia meu amigo
perdão pelos Barrão foi mal a rua fica
lindo em tal lugar e papá não tem nada a
ver com um dia viu tamo junto é nós não
precisava Solução Não precisava foi foi
Nada justifica sabe atitude de todos os
brothers
e foram todos por mais que a carga mais
pesada tenha caído na minhas costas e
tem pessoas que acham que a saída dele
no dia fui eu que motivo é aquele dia a
gente tava se falando tranquilo é óbvio
que eu tive atitudes bem deprimente
antes mas não foi a motivação ali
naquele momento era uma outra situação
que aconteceu não amanhã eu tiro uma
rejeição Total local sentiu que é é e eu
reconheço que eu contribuí para esse
sentimento dele de desistência todo
mundo ali teve esse sentimento é natural
né esse sentimento mas eu poderia ter
agido de outra forma e ele é um menino
muito inteligente então a dentro e
tentava É como sua cabeça dele e
explodir de tanta informação outra coisa
que eu tinha para falar e tanta coisa e
lá tava todo mundo focado no jogo ou em
si próprio seus egos e aí artista
artista é egocêntrico já começa aí por
isso eu não entendi esse julgamento do
olha como ela é narcisista egocêntrico
gente eu sou Artes
e não existe um artista que subir a um
Palco que a chamada de Diva e não se
sinta porque senão egocêntrico não
quando chegar lá em cima nem vai fazer o
que tem que fazer como é que vai chegar
cantando que você falando sobre poder
estar bem se você chega com então a
artista a diva né que eu nunca me
considerei uma diva mas o público faz
isso com a gente então a diva ela ela é
narcisista então eu tenho traços nesses
não sei se alguns correto jeito que eu
tô falando quando eu chego na cidade
para fazer show eu não gosto que ninguém
me veja é porque para não perder a graça
não entendeu eu sou eu quero que a
pessoa da sua mãe entendeu então tipo
assim eu tô na van aí vou sair para
Hotel Aí eu saio da Van e vou se tá
legal porque que o Whindersson faz isso
é uma intensidade tão legal galera que é
um lado
e fica um pouco divo entendeu é meu
amiguinho eu preciso ser um pouquinho é
você precisamos normalizar a cilada
egocêntrico dos Artistas é porque se a
gente não tivesse a pergunta daquele
sabe é Então imagina eu chegar igual eu
tava toda assim capenga lá no meu
estudio aí chegou dois amigos Ah não
cadê a Carol com ka poderosa eu quero a
Karol Conká poderosa cadeia vai lá minha
língua chicote e eu assim ó falar eu não
vou mais falar dessas coisas eu comecei
a escrever música para o meu avô um novo
eu falar não eu não vou falar isso aqui
aí eu direi Por que não falei acho que
um sonho ele Ah não sério for eu acho
que agora sentindo que tu tava dando um
Babá caindo eu não tô legal cantar é que
tá sentindo assim né tava se sentindo
empoderado aí Rizzi grandona é que eu
não conseguia botar assim eu mando eu
quero eu pego naquele
e eu tava seguir nem nada dentro da sua
cabeça e sentindo uma bola de bolha de
sabão sabe quando a bolha de sabão ela
fica flutuando vento então ficou uma
coisa assim então quando eu saio você
então ai tô assim assim assado depois
você cai na realidade Veste a roupa da
humildade entende bebe um chá da
humildade fala espera eu não preciso me
me armar tão desse jeito Não há
necessidade disso e é muito julgamento
para tudo no meu caso tá assim não se eu
sorrir é fingimento Se Eu Chorar é
fingimento ficar séria fingimento se eu
falar qualquer coisa fingimento fala até
da cor das roupas que eu uso que eu
sempre usei todos os tons de cores vai
ser o pedaço que eu vou botar o trailer
é tudo atingimento falando forma que
saco poxa eu cheguei eu assisti o
coringa quando eu sair do eu acho que
tipo assim hoje eu vou ter que está
chegando só vou pedir para ti de novo
pela terceira vez vamos beber
e vamo fazer gente eu vou assistir o
coringa aqui deixa meu filho minha mãe
vai vamo assistir o Coringa é meu filho
falou de novo eu fui não vamos entender
assim aí a minha mãe mais porque a minha
mãe não tinha assistido ainda falei para
ela a gente julga
a analogia meio bolo Mas tudo bem mas a
gente julga ele tá fazendo atrocidades e
não ver o que aconteceu antes a pessoa
que machuca ela foi machucada todo mundo
já sabe desse processo o bullying quem
quem faz bullying já sofreu bullying e
aí a falta de amor de acolhimento e para
tia faz com que essas atitudes elas vão
se inflando dentro das pessoas mais
corretas que existem no no mundo então
eu assistindo aquilo eu conseguia
entender a parte humana da Vila aqui que
eu eu transformei e o público amplificou
porque você sabia todos os porquês eu
sabia os porquês mas o público não então
a gente só foi entender esse lado do
Coringa quando a gente viu esse filme
que fala sobre as feridas ele a gente
sente dó de um vilão Quando ver ele
sendo massacrado antes de cometer as
atitudes dele só que ninguém viu as
cenas que eu vivi passei de
o que humilhação para chegar nível de
chegar no programa desse no reality e
age como se eu tivesse lidando com essas
pessoas que me maltrataram durante essa
trajetória na minha carreira e essas
pessoas elas continuam me perseguir e
depois desse óleo coletivo e desse
cancelamento ela se sentiram mais fortes
então elas continuam tripudiando e
brincando com essa situação de vilania
real do lado dele então Eles continuam
na ameaça continua na humilhação
continuo tentando tirar todas as
possibilidades que eu tenho de seguir
minha carreira porque na cabeça deles eu
preciso ser cancelada de vez e ele tem
meu amigo meu que ele falou assim Carol
eu falei nossa você tá aqui eu achei que
você não ia mais falar comigo você não
ia ser meu amigo e todos os meus amigos
continuarão né tá todo mundo aqui e tudo
Ele falou Carol que ele não tá agora
nunca esteve
e eu fiquei refletindo sobre isso pra
ela nunca esteve ele falou e outra se
cada atitude que você teve ali todo
mundo que tá jogando não tiver feito 10
por cento do que você fez aí são todos
Alecrins Dourados como tá falando né não
usou a palavra empatia mas ele praticou
a palavra para tia tá ligado ele
praticou porque ele se colocou no seu
lugar e disse se cada um de nós não
tiver feito igual que que Jesus disse
quando a galera tava com uma pedra conte
pra mim atire a primeira pedra quem
nunca pecou atire a primeira pedra que
aquele que nunca tomba clique no botão
Quando eu via eu falava assim Gente é
muita gente se unindo para não gostar de
uma pessoa tá ligado Tipo assim muita
gente tem gente tem gente que é bom a
gente se unir para não mostrar mais
e não é bom fazer isso tá ligado não
gostar de tipo aquele que a pessoa morra
e e ficar desejando isso vendo que
também um monte de gente tá desejando tá
ligado eu percebi até uma coisa em mim
que eu não percebia que era aquele
negócio que eu falei ele tipo tem um
teto parece que para mim tem um teto
para maldade né tipo você fala não que a
pessoa alguma coisa ali tá bom eu quero
que ela saia aí quando ela sair ela vai
perder um contrato entendeu a gente tem
que ter um duas marcas boa top grande
entendeu tem uma depois tá bom bebê e
depois tá bom entendeu só que aí que a
gente vê que não tem limite para isso as
pessoas passam do limite se você
contribui um pouquinho para isso você
ajuda por isso que eu tipo tirei meu
time de campo sem por cento isso aí não
não vou fazer piada que eu não quero
ganhar um seguidor em cima disso não tô
afim a deve perfil que
o que usou meu nome para ganhar seguidor
para é assim que eu sair que tinha que
tinha alguma coisa a ver com você que
tem um milhão e tanto é que em três
milhões mas assim sabe o que que eu
penso mesmo sendo algo negativo uma
repercussão negativa eu ajudei essas
pessoas de alguma forma mas essa sabe
deixa eu te contar uma parada assim que
talvez te esclareça esclareça não eu nem
vou falar essa palavra que é do pai mais
falando né mas é é não das palavras que
que tiver como que fala então que te
seria o seguinte a percepção que a
galera tem sobre a gente atingir muita
gente entendeu sim essa parada de TV
foram muitas pessoas só que se você
parar para prestar atenção não importa
se foram muitas pessoas entendeu
o importa se fosse uma importaria assim
entendeu a gente pensa que a gente tenha
a obrigação de explicar para todo mundo
o que aconteceu só que a gente não tem
ser ser uma pessoa pública se era
pública parece que dispara a gente
automaticamente tipo assim não não você
não pode deixar de fica assim você tem
que fazer isso e você tem que fazer aqui
só que você tem que fazer o melhor para
você você não tem que fazer uma melhor
para o empresário não tem que fazer
melhor se você sou você não tem que
fazer o melhor para ninguém sabe porque
cada um tem sua caminhada a pessoa que
trabalhou com você se ela deixar
trabalhar com você hoje abre caminhada
dela amanhã é procurar alguém para
trabalhar não é senhor tirou meu não não
é isso não a Carol é uma pessoa que
passou pela vida dela como qualquer um
ano é porque você artista né para você
famosa a mas olha o que eu passei por
situações do tipo tá trabalhando no
lugar comprei
eu me senti sufocada e desrespeitada
pedir para sair e a pessoa sair falando
que acabou a vida dela porque eu
respeitei meu livre arbítrio de querer
sair de querer de não estar no mesmo
ambiente e a pessoa isso tem muitos anos
e a pessoa até hoje carrega essa
amargura de ela me abandonou por causa
dela por ela não estar aqui a minha vida
acabou e assim que poder é esse que eu
tenho de anular a vida de qualquer outra
pessoa só tô tão ocupada com a minha
vida para construir a minha sabe que eu
tenho todo esse poder a vacina já
estaria aqui com todo mundo então eu
fico pensando que fala assim eu se eu
não culpo as outras pessoas pelas minhas
falhas e derrotas eu não vou deixar aqui
me faça um responsável pelas derrotas
alheias porque eu sei exatamente o que
eu faço e o que eu falo e eu percebo que
não foi nada além de erros momentâneos
o que só fez mal para mim não mal para
essas pessoas que a pessoa né é eu nunca
roubei eu nunca deixei de pagar e
tiveram muita gente teve muita fake News
teve apareceu o grupo de bailarino
dizendo que eu não paguei ele seu com
documento comprovando que eles foram
pagos é muito triste aparecendo dizer
assim olha o seguinte e ela saiu comer
um açaí aqui e não pagou não viu sério
aí eu falo assim tá vou pode é mais
fácil pra ela tá sendo uma vaca lá
dentro um lixo do que ficar inventando
aqui não me vamos aproveitar agora que
ela tá queimada vai ser a palavra dela
contra a nossa e com certeza não
acredita na gente que ela já vilã Não
porque eu tenho provas documentos que
comprovam que eu fiz as coisas certinho
então é muito ruim eu já tinha uma
desconfiança uma dificuldade de confiar
nas pessoas e agora fica pior sabe eu
preciso passar dessa etapa de eu preciso
confiar nas pessoas aconteceu com muito
começo essa parada de mim
o fio terra no quinto eu confio porque a
realidade da pessoa é que a pessoa me
mostra isso tipo se ela tiver mostrando
uma coisa que ela não é então eu tô que
vendido aqui porque eu tô adorando ser
amigo dessa pessoa que [ __ ] é tudo isso
que ela tá falando tá ligado né que tá
ligado esse cara tá dizendo que fez
investimento esse fez aqui ele papai e
tem um negócio louco para conversar
comigo ela e tudo mais Está tanto pode
ser uma pessoa que tem realmente um
investimento massa uma parada Legal ou
pode ser realidade que o carro também
mostrando que não é a verdadeira
entendeu e eu posso estar viajando na
maionese Não tô aqui não
e não tá acontecendo e a gente aí [ __ ]
sempre eu converso com alguém eu conto
toda minha vida toda eu conto meus
projetos todo e bota música para ouvir
Mas eu também Ai meu Deus eu sou Calebe
quero fazer isso quero fazer aquilo e
vou fazer isso vou fazer isso isso e
aqui nesse aqui e vou contando tudo e a
pessoa eu também vai me mostrando sei o
que ela quer e mostrar é é só o que ela
quer o que ela acha que é legal dela aí
depois eu não sei que a pessoa não paga
não sei quem ou que a pessoa não tem
preta com um amigo meu não sei aonde
porque pegou um não sei quem Não
deixasse ela fica sabendo depois só
depois que você já contou tudo que eu
sou assim eu tô conversando com a pessoa
eu [ __ ] quando tudo já era então essa
coisa de ideia eu aprendi a né mas assim
muito de falar tipo assim é mais você vê
a vida não Big Brother Mas você vê a
vida como um game
é realmente realmente tem jogadores que
estão mais à frente no ligado eles são
esperto Eles são muito nasce eles eles
são muito bons alinhado eles são bons em
convencer e conversar em manipular tá
ligado E aí o que que tem que acontecer
o que tem que acontecer é que você tem
que ter um primeiro despertar que é tipo
assim qual é o meu game é bom ou é ruim
é bom né então tá então tudo que vem
daqui para cá eu sempre um pé atrás eu
não digo nunca não para tudo que eu que
eu não concordo porque a malícia às
vezes é bom um pouquinho para você
entender algumas peças do game tá ligado
precisa de perto uma licencinha e é bom
se entender e tudo mais mas tipo assim
você tem que estar muito Alerta
e com as pessoas porque é como se fosse
realmente o Big Brother o que acontece
comigo por exemplo eu aprendi como você
falou agora você aprendeu a a questão
das ideias depois que eu aprendi eu tô
conversando com você aqui Chegou outra
pessoa eu paro tá ligado É porque meu
amigo se é meu Esse é bom de banheiro em
a nossa tá grande é que o boleto não dá
para ver a depressão é um problema que
as pessoas não entendem geralmente a
pessoa não entende isso não falam não se
fala muito que você você não entende
muito eu vou falar uma barata e não vai
entender eu já não entendo então eu vou
ficar mais confuso Então é melhor não
falar eu não falo tá ligado aí amanhã eu
falo assim quer saber eu vou tomar um
banho eu vou fazer minha barba e eu vou
em dias normais cartãozinho eu vou no
cinema entendeu E aí você vai no cinema
fala assim vai tá com depressão vai no
cinema para gente eu tô tentando sair do
ponto a ao. B entendeu E vocês estão lá
e-mail me pedindo vocês também não é rei
tentando me me dizer que eu devo ficar
de uma forma e sim é sempre essa é igual
quando eu falei tô com uma tristeza
profunda não consigo
eu me senti feliz aí me falaram Ah pára
né você deu picos de audiência você
estava maravilhosa bonito de audiência
desse jeito quem se gosta para eu não
acho interessante eu não gosto triste ah
mas você é conhecida a mas você tem
talento você pode fazer música e de sair
por cima normal entendeu para ele você
não é uma pessoa normal você é alguém
imaculado realmente diferente para você
entra dentro do carro ele segundo nem
transformam e aparece no Rio de Janeiro
e não é assim que parada aí eu fico
triste aí falar mas já foi ao pior já
passou e você tava lá dentro você nem
viu falam pior para quem assiste agora o
pior para quem é aquilo e viveu Aquilo é
outra história então a minha batalha é
não cair numa depressão diz eu faço
acompanhamento para não cair numa
depressão que tem várias coisas que
pegam Né desde o trauma de
se for ao se reconhecer no mas isso aí
não tem tanto controle não tenho Ainda
me sinto em vendido assim vc me sinto
vendida me sinto uma coisa como se fosse
um negócio que as pessoas vão para lá e
para cá e tiram suas próprias conclusões
E aquele negócio é outra coisa e ter que
lidar com isso com a rejeição dessas
pessoas e ainda com a insistência de
inimigos que não se contentam ainda
tenho que dizer para si mesmo tipo todo
dia vai dar certo vai dar certo isso
também vai passar isso também vai passar
é é uma e assim muitos falam mas você
deveria voltar e moço tá muito sumida
das redes chega e mostra que você tá
arrasando que você tá é poderosa mostra
aonde você tá eu falo para quê Por quê
que eu vou fazer isso ai para a gente
saber o que que você tá fazendo mas para
quê
Ah entendeu porque eu não tô bem Ah mas
duvido que ela tá maus Não eu não estou
bem não tô legal entendeu então assim é
óbvio que eu consigo dar risadas durante
o dia de algumas coisas mas são creme se
fosse em outra situação essa entrevista
a gente já tá indo muito mais porque o
meu natural essa é uma coisa mais cômica
e as pessoas acham que a força ou rimas
fortes não estão ligados a bom amor o
que o deboche ele não pode estar ligado
a o sarcasmo que tá ligado a uma com a
mente criativa o brasileiro é debochado
a gente é sarcástico o tempo inteiro aí
de Boston do meu deboche e eu não posso
debochar do meu próprio deboche e
devolver o deboche do The Voice que tá
debochando a
G1
e já que é para a filosofia filosofia
que é tombar não tem que eu vou tomar
mais que eu já tô bem gente ó falaram
para mim do chão não passa mas eu acho
que eu passei eu fui até o Inferno Natal
deixa eu não passa Quase que eu fiz
igual leoneses e se do céu no pole dance
até o inferno foi isso que você
tranquilo eu tava lá no céu de repente ó
de preferido eu fui a Só faltou Sentar
no Colo do capeta legal você viu sem
Equipe do Leonardo meu Deus ele
literalmente Senta no Colo do cabelo tá
e tenta muito bem ele também para fazer
uma parada a parada é bem chocante e
você vai ter que lidar com tudo aquilo
que vem depois tá tem que estar muito
bem às vezes eu penso em fazer uns
trabalhos assim também não agora uma
coisa chocante assim mas eu fiquei com
vontade de fazer uma coisa chocante ao
sendo apedrejada secar tejada foi ele
que fez tudo o que é é porque o nosso
lado artista ele quer expressão é isso
sabe aquele passinho do Recife com a
galera fazer você amo sim falar galera
tem uma melhor ali e aí a ela se une
culturalmente expressa alguma coisa que
sai alguma forma que alta isso aí aquele
saiu que é uma parada bem É o tome tome
toma toma toma isso mesmo É ela também
isso é uma como se
a mensagem de favela é a mensagem é essa
ela diz isso É expressada daquele
momento porque é que ele é ótimo Ai ela
peça não adianta você quer expressar ela
de algum jeito ou era uma música Tanto
que quando por exemplo uma pessoa que é
um civil normal ele nenhum cantor em um
compositor mas às vezes aniversário de
namoro ele faz eu vou fazer uma música
para ela aí ele escreve aquela
musiquinha bem simplinha conversas bem
simples mas é ele que tem expressar um
pouquinho espremendo o coração dele e
saindo um pouquinho de arte tá ligado
Então dou maior valor essa parada de
você se expressar de alguma forma em é
uma música é um estilo tá gente canta
muitas vezes sobre aquilo que a gente
quer ou a gente é ou a gente teve no meu
caso O Poder Em alguns momentos me senti
poderosa em outros não e também em
alguns casos se a gente não se sente o
que que é de nós
a gente não tem o ditado se você não se
sente [ __ ] quem que vai te achar faltam
assim a gente vive numa sociedade que
fala que não pode julgar mais julga que
fala para ter mais autoestima mas
reprime a pessoa mais chama de
egocêntrico psicopata uma pessoa que se
sente bem ou chama de como que é ixi deu
um branco que eu entendi tipo a pessoa a
pessoa se põe no seu lugar onde pode ser
impor um pouco e aí você não pode né eu
tenho essa Portal É é na possa eu não
posso aí eu falo mais perto eu tinha que
ser submissa Eu tenho esse problema na
cabeça não quero ser uma mulher submissa
a porque Carol fala tanto disso pô mas
porque eu cresci Numa família onde
mulheres não eram submissas mulheres
eram fortes minha avó era espancada todo
dia para o meu vô ele só parou quando
ela reagiu e quando ela reagiu ele saiu
de casa então eu aprendi
se você reagir você vai ser vista como
vê-lo sempre além de espantar o problema
para você né sua leitura sua visão é que
você tá espantando o problema sim
independente das atitudes que eu tive na
casa se eu não tivesse tido aquelas
aquele tom agressivo ainda assim talvez
eu estaria cancelada ou por não ter me
posicionado ou por ter me posicionado na
hora errada ou por ter a verdade que não
e talvez fosse Pior né porque tipo de
agora quando tipo a galera tipo [ __ ]
quer que isso de reduzir ao zero aí tu
tem de onde Ressurge né aí tipo se tu
tivesse ido só cancelada pela metade e
tivesse tipo uma situação chata agora né
a sentar-se re entendendo isso imagina
só tivesse tipo lidando com aquele
falando a galera é ruim mim é e me
criticar eu ia continuar montada na sua
barba que é onde eu estava quando eu
estava no reality quer não há qualquer
coisa minha qualquer coisa respeita
macia tá pelo amor de Deus feita bacia
meu Deus eu me perdoo vontade não não
não nada não tem vontade de nada a gente
está acostumado a ter tudo do nosso
jeito na nossa vida então escutamos quer
que eu quiser a hora que eu quiser eu
vou trabalhar o horário que eu quiser às
vezes não mas eu gosto também eu gosto
muito de trabalhar Acho que ele não
ambiente não é do jeito que você quer eu
fui uma animada às vezes eu às vezes eu
paro também para mim olhar para mim um
pouco e falar assim eu tenho que cuidar
um pouco para não virar uma pessoa
porque acontece isso comigo também tipo
a gente a gente quer beber o negócio e
isso não gosta aparece
tu tá ligado que tem sim já tem uma
produção e tem uma galera que trabalha e
quer trabalhar sabe se vai fazer as
coisas tudo rápido para gente né E se
quer agradar bem direitinho é não faltar
nada então tipo assim a gente fala que
quer comer o negócio pensa final negócio
tá ali a gente se quer fazer uma parada
isso aqui não já tá feito aqui esse
negocinho aqui eu falei que queria o
podcast nesse já tá no Face tá ligado
isso a gente acostumada com isso tem que
cuidar um pouquinho para não acostumar
tanto com isso que não perder a
realidade assim Sabe às vezes eu eu fico
falando com os meninos também tipo
e eu converso com os meninos e fico
esperando que eles me corrigir um pouco
aí eu vivo isso credo eu faço muitas
vezes é só para ver alguém falar Não não
faz isso não eu quero saber se a galera
tá online tá
é porque eu eu gosto de me cercar de
pessoas que falam não é o tal do Fala na
cara porque essa frase fala na cara é
muito agressiva quer dizer que a pessoa
fala não mede nada só mesma eu não sou
uma pessoa assim que fala na cara Eu
meço mas falava mas eu gosto de pessoas
que sejam reais então eu estou viajando
e eu sou pirado eu falo eu pirado no bom
sentido agora viu fica a Travessa me
falar que eu sou pirata mas quando eu
sou eu tenho uma mente criativa não tem
uma começa assim nossa eu vou viajar
para tal lugar a fazer isso esses sabe
só falar e vai se incrível aí eu falo
para uma outra Pois eu vou até o três na
terceira se nessas três alguém falar não
só que aí eu já olha aquelas outras duas
e achamos para conversa eu falo você me
deixar fazer isso e você sabe que ela
sabe da sua agenda essa pela sábado a
sua o que tem que fazer essa daqui
apoiando a fazer uma parada que não tem
como você fazer porque com agenda lotada
então tipo é bom você ficar esperto ali
naquele momento Sempre tem aquela pessoa
o que pó da gente que eu amo que
precisamos disso que fala ó não é bem
por aí e tem aquelas pessoas que apoiam
Nossa loucura e as pessoas que falam
Olha onde tiver indo Tamo Aí eu quero
ver você bem então tem que no momento
que eu saí da casa dos dois meses assim
posso sair daí eu ficava eu ficava assim
meu Deus eu não confio mais na minha
intuição no meu achismo mas porque Carol
tem que confiar em você eu falo como eu
botei eu botei no Heat 1 mês eu confiei
lá dentro também não acertei nas eu não
acertei vamos ver o que que eu acertei
falando assim eu francamente hahaha Deus
Olha eu acho muito bom para trás ver as
cagadas que eu também sou desse jeito
também o que que é isso que eu só não
sou filmado Só não sou filmado mas eu
totalmente puro
em 24 horas por dia tentando encontrar
um erro umas coisas que eu falei um
negócio que eu não quis dizer um negócio
que eu não quis pensar porque às vezes
tem o pensamento também eu falar tudo
que eu pensamento entendeu a gente
máquina sai pela boca máquinas aquela
bom mais não tá dando muita besteira
muito ainda bem que você não assistiu
deve ser por isso o Brasil que ele me
recebe aqui porque ele não viu o que
vocês viram Eu também Nossa então já viu
o suficiente é lá onde tá na hora que tá
o mesmo nossa eu falei muita besteira e
ali para quem me conhece meus fala nossa
tá com ataque de ansiedade Sinistro e as
pessoas não sabem o que é ansiedade né
tanto que meu DJ que trabalha comigo eu
sou mais o que a ansiedade mesmo em se
ela tem ela tem várias características
problema pressão né
eu explico a todo mundo tipo assim
absolve depressão gente a depressão não
é só ficar triste a depressão ela faz
você perder as pessoas que você ama tá
ligado porque a pessoa vem falar uma
parada com você
eu e ela não entende e você não entende
também tá ligado vai vai tomar no cu
então então vai pra [ __ ] que pariu tá
entendendo é assim também tá ligado Tipo
assim não é só igual a palavra empatia
para a empatia eu me bota no lugar do
não é muito mais Alô do que eu mais
amplo não é só se colocar no lugar do
outro é você é você se eliminar o seu
ego vai dar de orgulho o que que bota o
celular lá e voltar você e se vê em cada
situação da preço da vida da pessoa e
você se troca não só da vida da pessoa
como da pessoa que certo a pessoa como
namorado outra pessoa como do amigo da
pessoa como da prima da prima da pessoa
você não quer que a pessoa lá no posto
em Roraima fique triste eu não quero
entendeu então tipo assim é isso tá
ligado Então da mesma forma eu ficava
tipo
se você afasta as pessoas que você gosta
de você entendeu você você faz as
pessoas que auto-sabotagem é uma
auto-sabotagem afastar mesmo que quando
a tem aquelas crianças que a gente fala
assim para não faz isso e a criança é
tão atentado aquela olha para tocar e
faz de novo
e eu me senti assim é quase como se ela
tivesse tentando mandar uma mensagem né
isso e geralmente quando quando é caso
de criança que é muito atentado assim é
que tem alguma coisa que não tá bem eu
falo isso porque eu era uma criança
muito espevitada depois Teve uma época
que eu fiquei impossível na sala de aula
e uma professora falou assim olha ela
faz isso porque ela não tem atenção em
casa ela quer chamar atenção e aquilo
ficou na minha cabeça eu cheguei em casa
eu falei mãe vocês não me dão atenção
porque a professora falou que eu quero
chamar atenção ela falou Olha você desde
pequena é muito
e estrelada daí ela brincava que é
porque eu tinha nascido O Primeiro de
Janeiro e aí eu ouvi os barulhos dos
fogos e fiquei e eu acreditava nisso né
essas histórias de família que tipo fala
que alguma coisa que a gente tem por que
aconteceu isso acaba nossa é isso né E
aí eu comecei a perceber Qual era a
situação que eu tinha na minha casa meu
pai alcoólatra meu irmão teve leucemia
com 5 aninhos minha mãe precisa ficar
com foco Total nele no hospital e eu me
sentia
e é rejeitada Mas isso é uma coisa que
eu sentia não que eles faziam comigo mas
eu me senti assim cadê a minha mãe cadê
o meu pai eu não entendi porque quando
eu fazia músicas de amor e poema para o
meu pai ele não estava ali para ouvir
ele preferia ficar no bar da aqui em
casa você vai entender que ele tinha uma
doença a doença do alcoolismo com 14 15
anos quando ele faleceu e aí eu comecei
a chamar atenção no colégio cirrose
e não ele então tem ele era doente né
tinha o alcoolismo só que ele morreu de
uma maneira muito estúpida ele
regurgitou a bebida respirou e foi para
o pulmão e aí dele morreu mas se não
fosse isso mais um pouquinho para frente
ele teria falecido uma filha de uma
amiga minha que ela espirrou e o catarro
entrou pelúcia É uma morte estúpida né
para você falar comigo aconteceu mas não
é para acontecer e eu fiquei muito tempo
mal porque eu não consegui me despedir
do meu pai eu uma vez discutindo com ele
uma semana antes da morte dele porque
ele era bêbado minha mãe já tinha
separado dele e ele tava morando com a
minha vó eu falei se eu for até aí te
visitar você tiver bêbado Eu nunca mais
vou e aí eu fui ele tava bêbado eu não
entendi aquele não tinha controle
controle eu não fui visitar
e ele começou a me ligar fazendo
contagem regressiva da morte dele isso
eu nunca contei eu contei no Doc e agora
sim que eu já tô resolvendo essas
questões com psicólogo terapeuta mas eu
não conseguia falar sobre isso nessa
levada de sair tem que conversar com a
galera para ajeitar a tua cabeça você já
tá ajeitando tudo sabe o frio no mundo
me despedir dele
Oi e ele falava faltam tantos dias
faltam três dias faltam dois dias aí ele
falou Amanhã você não vai me ver e eu
nunca mais vi ele e eu falei ele chamou
a morte porque ele falava que queria
morrer entendeu antes de todo o dele ir
morar com a minha avó ele comentava que
a vida não tinha graça meu pai tinha
depressão Eu só fui entender mais para
frente mais velha e ele falava eu não
quero viver e parece o a morte foi tão
estúpida que eu pensei Ele chamou a
morte depois eu vi minha tia falando eu
não vejo mais graça ela teve mieloma
indo E aí quando eu me vi na situação de
quero morreu lembrava do meu pai que
quando ele falava não tenho mais vontade
de viver lembrei da minha tia quando ela
falou a mesma coisa que perdeu a graça
do mundo e eu me senti igual assim nossa
não vejo graça no mundo e aí na equipe
minha família amigos começaram não você
fez coisa errada fez mas olha quanta
coisa boa você Já construiu aí eu tive
que
e esse processo você mesmo a construir
Esse camina é porque pode estar milhões
de pessoas ao seu redor falando vai
levanta levanta se você não levanta nada
vai te levantar e pode ter milhares de
pessoas falando deita deita e você falar
eu vou levantar até todos aplaudirem a
sua levantadas e
a nossa essa coisa de você
e não sente à vontade de estar aqui né
eu eu falo assim que quando
o que a gente podia não estar né aqui
mas ele tá
e a gente podia não tá gente não está
aqui mas está se a gente tá porque não
fazer dessa passagem né uma coisa muito
incrível para nós mesmo entendeu porque
tipo assim o que tu o que tu deve tá
sentindo agora uma parada de tipo
reconquistar uma galera só que tipo a
parada tem que ser legal para nós mesmo
não se gostar muito você falou muito bem
alto ao mundo né sobre alto sobre isso
auto-sabotagem tá ligado Então tem uma
parada muito da gente se achar
Oi querido eu descobri que a minha
soberba eu comecei a prestar atenção
nessas duas da sua beba foi uma perita a
gente acha que a soberba tá ligado é só
que eu tivesse eu consigo comigo que
aconteceu com você eu acho que eu teria
esquecido aquela pessoa de dentro já não
não teria não estaria mais contando com
aquilo ali então não seria mais base e
além de estudo já foi é isso sou tudo é
isso não formas para mim não faz nem um
pouco de sentido não não eu não me vejo
ali eu acho que eu fico diferente depois
ficou mais mais Branda a ficou diferente
depois ficou mais Branda não na verdade
eu sempre fui mais desse jeito é desse
mais tranquila a única diferença é que
eu sou mais alegre e mas Tânia mais
cômica agora é na minha vida natural sou
mais Come que mais alegre do que isso no
momento ainda tô sabe assim
um todo tem uns mais por ser um pouco de
porcentagem que eu fico irritada com
aquela Carol mas tu já viu o tipo que
tem que por pessoas que têm histórias
sensacionais na vida tipo e e você não é
diferente dessas pessoas eu eu me para
me confortar de muitas coisas que eu
penso eu penso isso eu penso que tipo
assim nossa tem gente que se recompõem
de uma situação que eu falo assim meu Ah
meu Deus eu não ia conseguir isso sério
não ia acontecer comigo Entendeu já no
teu caso eu vejo que é uma coisa que dá
para
tu tá ligado que é uma coisa que é que
não está falando não crime não é um não
tem nada rolou um peso apesar de não se
passam que foi acho que assim já chegar
me falar isso você é tão criativa com as
coisas que até na hora da vilania da sua
amargura do seu stress eu tinha
criatividade é isso que fascinou E se o
público a querer a perder jamais mas
ainda assim eles preferem ficar falando
de mim então qualquer coisa que aconteça
eles lembram daquela Carol tanto que
transformaram queria saber quem foi
pessoa que fez o meme do paredão Como
assim foi do nada e tenho Fogo porque
realmente não foi quando aconteceu foi
depois muito depois gente eu tava quieta
no meu canto aí no meu no meu celular
começa a apertar Assessoria assim Carol
você tá vendo que tá acontecendo nas
redes eu falei não não tô acessando
e veja a Carol e a boquinha chegando eu
tinha e sabe essa boquinha vou explicar
quebrou-se da onde é que só meu amigo
Boss in drama se ligou é que a gente
quando a gente tá junto a gente fala que
a dica é tão frito de fazer música que a
gente começa a falar assim e a gente é
do Paraná então a gente tira saldo a
gente mesmo nosso tá aqui ele é do
interior então ele sempre ela a gente
começa a carregar nosso sotaque Eu estou
muito contente com esse presente e aí
tem esse esse aqui dentro da gente
praticamente dementes da tudo assim sabe
E aí e a gente faz essa boquinha do vou
te bater guri ar e eu fiz essa boca
em qualquer coisa entendeu E aí eu pego
e eu ai gente agora já consigo seguida
essa situação mas a boquinha e a cara
fechada Também quebrou o braço 1999 hoje
fala e fala sorrindo Mas na semana que
quebrou dói legal não não é tipo assim
passou o tempo a gente consegue clicar e
é o que eu digo aos meus amigos também
que eu estou muito triste hoje para você
amigo daqui a uns 4 anos Isso é só uma
lembrança engraçada para você nossa é
uma lembrança engraçada você vai rir
você vai destacar essa situação a torto
EA direito a pessoa vai falar assim que
você não ficou mal por isso você falou
assim fiquei passou meu Deus a boquinha
tô aqui ainda tem o quanto que eu só fui
ver depois que eu sei que tem o tal do
ponto ainda é que eu continuo viu
falando mesmo qualquer coisa me bota no
paredão entendeu daí faz a boquinha que
eu faço com base drama que eu tenho
máquina bem bonita lá fora
a hipótese não é nem pronto e esse ponto
eu e o bando entrou falando assim e aí
ele falava assim amiga parecia que você
tava eu e você no estúdio você tirando
onda ele falou aqui fora o povo achando
que você era toda aquela pessoa amarga é
igual que eu deveria falou Desculpe
gente mas ele já boquinha e o povo assim
a boca de noia ai eu adoro esse povo é
gente não ficar aqui um pouquinho de
[ __ ] dela aí eu ficava voltando vídeo
acho que milhares de pessoas votaram só
a parte que eu fico e pronto e pronto a
esse ponto aí tem sei
e a babá do veneno vídeo no YouTube como
uma hora de me bota no paredão se
acredita esquece juro para você olha
quando eu vi eu falei Quinho Quinho meu
Deus faz isso eu seria essa pessoa o
Gaara parou melhor que eu sou essa
pessoa ligou do celular que eu tô sem
consumir qualquer coisa me bota no
paredão qualquer coisa me bater na
parede ao qualquer coisa sem parar uma
hora eu falei não é possível atenção de
15 minutos de uma hora porque a galera
para não é burra e essa fala foi mais a
safadeza onde o que que aconteceu nesse
dia eu lembrar foi logo após a cena
deprimente da mesa
é um combo de coisa que dão conta de
moral não lembrava todos não gostaram
daquela cena mas fizeram meme daquela
cena que tanto machuca todo mundo me
machuca também e aí você consegue
entender o Brasil eu sou igual Brasil
Brasil a mim no sentido de eu achei que
era só eu que tirava a sala da própria
desgraça para aliviar a dor mas acho que
a dor foi tão grande que o brasileiro
que eles tiraram sábado esse momento
para dar uma aliviada na recepção sei lá
então tomar uma pandemia momento ali a
galera tava tava bem intensa tava bem
estranha também para as pessoas
esquecerem o número de mortes por que o
vídeo no nosso país para me apedrejar aí
você vê que a população não tá muito bem
da cabeça priorizar o linchamento de uma
artista em desequilíbrio emocional no
reality ao invés de priorizar cuidados
com com vigiando Eu não sei o que pensar
eu levo a sério esse hate é um rede de
um pouco e erra mais do que eu
E aí eu também não tiro a igual a culpa
da galera que culpa para falar a verdade
quem tem nesse mês essa dessa Arrasou
nele né a [ __ ] loucura razão Não dou
porque não tem razão para dar para isso
também tá ligado Tipo é que nem eu
estava te falando tipo algo Eu curti os
primeiros momentos de tortura mas se eu
estivesse fora também é curtir não pode
falar isso Não não eu já falei querida
tá se achando eu vou falar com ela que
você quer provar eu sei porque eu sou
igual medida eu comecei a ver que tava
muita gente eu comecei a ver que era
todo mundo aí eu comecei a ver com a
galera tava combinando de tirar na maior
de todos os tempos aí eu pera aí galera
que vocês estão aquela manejando da né a
modinha da dança Tik Tok então todo
mundo faz tanta todo mundo fazendo a
há milhões de like seguidores hoje a
dancinha é odiar a Karol Conká mas
ninguém quis levantar um ter uma série
sobre o que estava acontecendo na casa
nem eu nem outros participantes merecem
ser julgados porque tem pessoas que
ficam julgando atitude do Lucas atitude
da Carol atitude de não sei quem Ninguém
merece ser julgado ninguém velho sabe
então eu vejo funcionais e povo aí não
são Santo ai passar pano o que era
Precisamos Falar Sobre o que é o
cancelamento e o que é a passada de pano
passa apoio é você ser cúmplice do erro
de alguém falar isso aí fingir que não
vi agora você a colher a falar Pontal
ele mostrar direção certa Isso faz parte
da evolução o cancelamento ele faz parte
de um outro de um sentido bem contrário
ao que é Divino o seu aumento tive medo
um tempo um tempo eu tive medo depois eu
já queria que me cancelasse lo
E essas em cima e cancelar logo a mão
que para de encher meu saco é eu tô
assim também não acontece eles não param
E aí depois eu posso ser a pensar que
realmente não não faz diferença a galera
não tudo bem tem aquele barco Inicial
que se dá o artista tensa e tudo mais
ela lá e abrir nenhum artista vez é só
uma figura pública mesmo às vezes é só
uma pessoa que falou uma merda uma uma
palavra e aí a galera faz o tal do
cancelamento mas que o cancelamento vira
mais uma palavra do que nem a tia do que
vai poder amento empatia cancelamento
entendeu realmente tipo é a galera Tenta
dar uma cancelada e a pessoa vai lá
entende seu erro e aí volta e acaba do
cancelamento realmente não acontece
vídeo fato cancelar corta é não dá até
porque ele tira tua criatividade ninguém
tira a tua a tua forma de se Reinventar
e nem minha disposição de me tornar uma
pessoa melhor então
e é muito ruim quando a gente transfere
a nossas angústias em outra pessoa é
ruim fazer isso eu falo por experiência
própria eu peguei minha angústia tentei
transferir numa briga com outras pessoas
e não me trouxe nada de bom então não
vai trazer nada de bom para essas
pessoas transferir e angústia dela em
cima de mim que tô tentando me tornar
uma pessoa melhor tô fazendo exatamente
o que eles me pediram para fazer vai se
tratar vai ser uma pessoa melhor aí eu
tô nesse processo Eles continuam tá
fingindo não é certo aí é lá agora
tatuando é morre Tá apareceu chorando
antes não chorou na saída do viagem só
chorando agora porque porque nós
artistas somos condicionados a ligar
também eu já eu já fiz soltando
hemorragia eu já fechou passando mal
tendo Mega sangramento e sorrindo você
ficou né show porque eu gosto de fazer
meus números são de Barbie jogos shampoo
alto Caicó
e nesse dia ele resolveu sair outro
lugar saiu assim no lugar e eu levantei
meu fora do lugar galera sorrindo e o
hahaha essa piada engraçada Ana Helena
curti falei puxa que puxa aqui para você
então meu braço e Sim voltou entrou de
lugar aí eu voltei e fiz o que está
fazendo shampoo lado pulando Saltitante
usava aquelas unhas gigantes de gel e é
o pulando lá um cabritinho assim o meu
meu calcanhar encontro conforme eu
corria pulava bateu na minha mão que
veio para trás assim bateu arrancou a
unha inteira com sangue e tudo eu
continuei o show bem Maravilhosa a unha
voando a cara de alguém essa pessoa
segurou a unha ficou aqui almoçando para
minha unha a unha e eu assim cantando o
negócio começou a sangrar e eu aqui
é maravilhosa acabou o show chamar um
bombeiro jogar um álcool aí deu muito eu
chorava eu falei gente quê que tá
acontecendo e a unha liga aí meu dizer
falou mas eu não vi na hora do show não
vi as pessoas não vem porque a gente já
está condicionado a gente se treinar
para isso show é show espetáculo
espetáculo então quando eu sair do
reality eu tava no modo Palco Show
espetáculo sei lá o que eu não mudo de
preciso estar bem apresentável mulher
mesmo na derrota mas o porquê isso Ela é
psicopata ela não tem sentimento não
porque eu sou uma artista ela dá
automática já porque eu não posso eu
aprendi na minha família aqui mulher
preta não pode ser vulnerável não pode
não pode demonstrar fraqueza porque o
que faz um racista sentir prazer é ver a
gente chorar então por isso eu não
chorei porque eu sabia que dentre
aqueles todos votos e Ódio coletivo
tinha também o ódio do racismo e fala
o dela cair e aqui tá isso na moral foi
por orgulho por ser uma gente eu sou uma
artista que faz rap muitos não me
consideram rapper mas o rappi ele não tá
ligado só a letra EA melodia que você
cria tá ligado ao estilo de vida e ser
rappi não tá no meu caso não tá ligado a
estar com arma ou notas de dinheiro
chacoalhando na frente da câmera é o
estilo Rap disse é ser uma mulher no
rappi Então não é só cantar uma um Show
em cima da batida e fazer gestos
agressivos tem um lance aqui que você
tem que saber jogar entendeu e eu tive
que passar por muitas situações para
chegar na posição que eu tô entender que
eu não cheguei até aqui para ser uma
fraca eu represento milhares de pessoas
mulheres que se identificam e se
identificavam comigo e vão virar se
identificar Então acho que a fraqueza
ela nunca pode estar ligada a mulher
preta principalmente
a cabeça é assim que funciona e vai
demorar muito tempo para isso sai da
minha cabeça Talvez isso nunca saia eu
tenho que me manter forte eu entendo
também tipo é como quando eu penso
Lógico que nada se compara né mas às
vezes eu penso quando as pessoas fazem
nossa conta com 70 ideia quando como
você faz tanta coisa eu falo assim cara
porque quem nasceu onde eu nasci tem que
fazer dez coisas para poder para poder
tá igual a vocês aqui obrigado eu não
tenho como um só ser engraçado eu tenho
que ser engraçada tudo seu melhor tem
que ser Boxeador tem que ser compositor
eu tenho que ser isso e aquele e aquele
aquele aquele porque senão eu não fosse
ninguém porque tem um cara que nasceu
aqui mais por perto que só por ele
cantar bem ele já tá na minha frente mas
tá ligado Tipo eu morei lá na [ __ ] nasce
na [ __ ] que pariu eu lá sei onde ninguém
quer saber
tá ligado nasceu ninguém quer saber as
capitais porque a galera pensa que isso
aqui é o mesmo de todos os lugares o
mesmo é sotaque nordestino sabe o que
você tá com textinho mas o Piauí tu és a
Tupi ao isso do Aracaju é gostou da da
de Natal Rio Grande do Norte Então você
tá aqui Natal teu gírias de Natal eu
falo eu não falo os pivete eu falo os eu
falo uns pinta suspeita é que é o nome
do Maloka tá ligado que é o nome do cara
que a gente já fala os guri é diferente
tem gente que acha que para ser de
Curitiba acho que eu falo bate que é no
Rio Grande do Sul que fala assim também
quando falam que você tá que não combina
comigo porque Como assim Paranaense
então eu já ouvi muito isso até os trens
ver uma preta Paranaense Curitibana
porque eu falo gente Ronaldinho Gaúcho
né é isso e o Ronaldinho Gaúcho a gente
fala aí o Ronaldinho é
e eu entendo também a mesma coisa assim
não é a mesma coisa Lógico que não é a
mesma mas é aquela parada do tipo
Ah pois não é não são tantos os estados
para saber quais são as capitais está
ligado não nossa e aí a gente é péssimo
e entender essas coisas porque que nem
eu não sou muito bom em Geografia nem
história eram professoras que não me
davam bem na época história no colégio
achava um saco porque ele falava dos
escravos não ajudou muito eu sempre fui
meio Rebelde com isso também que eu
falar para que falar dos escravos desse
jeito a prova mais não tem outro lugar
que a gente veio nasceu da Tábua do
Navio Negreiro não tem outra coisa E aí
depois você vê que tem outra coisa só
que a gente aprende só Pelas nossas
famílias Mas por que não fala no colégio
então não vou assistir essa aula vou
sair não vou arranjar um problema com
essa professora não me sinto confortável
Então eu tinha essa rebeldia assim sabe
por me sentir Curitibana deslocada agora
nem Curitiba me quer né
em Curitiba e voltou no paredao Brasília
botou no paredao eu me botei no paredão
e o próprio paredão me botou no paredão
[ __ ] parou né Eu não sei o que você
acha que eu tenho que ser pregado numa
cruz fica Povo Precisa De verdade é que
hoje em dia é o apedrejamento o
lixamento Ele é virtual eu não sei se
isso é bom ou ruim porque se fosse
Antigamente eu não estaria nem aqui para
dar entrevista agora teria sido jogada
por isso eu te pego' ao vivo assim eu tô
no processo de parar de me auto flagela
Mel do seu botar entender que só um ser
humano a a soberba também tá ligada no a
eu errei Poxa fiz cagada que merda minha
vida eu achar que nada mais está
acontecendo a não ser a decepção mas o
mundo tem tantas outras que a gente é só
esse tamanho aqui sabe para eu entender
que assim também a soberba pode
e também é essa falta de compreensão
assim não tá em mas vamos ver que que eu
posso fazer ali na frente ainda mais
quando a gente meio que se quando a
gente entende que a gente realmente tem
que buscar o nosso lugar no mundo
entender porque antes a gente não tava
com o nosso lugar no mundo por isso que
a gente fica meio assim perdido continuo
me sentindo falo e agora onde eu vou
antes eu pessoal sabe o que eu gostava
tipo assim
Olá pessoal tipo assim ah tá ganhei
dinheiro então tipo que eu tô fazer
agora a Eu quando era novo eu queria que
alguém me ajudasse Então eu tenho que
ajudar as pessoas a então é esse Ah
então entendi então tipo tudo que for
para mim tem que dizer para mim e mais
um monte de gente também agora agradar
não para ajudar um monte de gente não
cria e meio que um propósito de de
sempre que eu ser beneficiado um monte
de gente sendo beneficiado também então
meio que virou um nortinho para mim é
isso essa pacote encontrar um nortinho
lugar para ir à sempre que eu for
trabalhar mas 35 pessoas também vão ter
suas famílias eles beneficiada com um
trabalho que o cara tava no tava sem
trabalhar e agora ele tem um trabalhando
por um tempo e tudo mais e E aí virou
meio isso talvez seja incrível a pessoa
encontrar tipo realmente coisas que
beneficiam não só você com várias outras
pessoas várias anti-g
É sim cara Leonardo Dicaprio eu até
falei hoje né Leonardo DiCaprio se ele
não ajudar Amazônia é só um ator de
Hollywood ele não é nada de diferente
além de tipo Brad Pitt fiz acho que esse
é a troca nós vemos o mundo que precisa
de troca não sou material eu digo troca
energética entender favor poxa a gente
precisa da Galera também burra Total
sempre é uma troca a gente precisa deles
eles precisam da gente e eu tô nesse
gente fica tão eu fiquei assim assim
para falar nossa como é que vai ser eu
vou trabalhar ninguém mais quer falar
comigo ninguém mais quer se associar
Amém e como é que fica aí minha equipe
eu pedindo desculpa por todo mundo
falando gente eu não vou conseguir
render como um dia antes porque eu fiz a
cagada de ter péssimas atitudes de
montado na soberba no reality então
vocês me perdoem a hora que tiver melhor
eu chamo vocês
a continuar comigo eu vou entender e
eles não a gente tá aqui não é na hora
do Ouro que a gente tá junto na hora da
isso vai passar Carol e eu falo também
porque está com você na
bom estar com você até na hora que você
tá subindo é mais fácil do que tá você
quando você tá no pulso é que quando
você tá subindo tá funcionando hoje é
dois mil amanhã a 5 e 500 amanhã 8:00
depois de amanhã já é 12 então tá sempre
uma constante então é muito bom tá com a
gente é muito bom tá com essa tá sempre
viajando você tá sempre legal você tá
sempre curtindo você tá sendo feliz
lógico que é ótimo Tá na minha a minha
caminhada é quem porque assim eu sempre
estende a mão e ajudei muitas pessoas se
eu tenho acolhimento agora Lembra
daquela nossa da começa no começo do Se
você dá você recebe eu recebo
acolhimento carinho e respeito porque eu
dei muito isso então se eu tivesse sido
uma pessoa realmente amarga todo ao
longo da minha vida eu não teria
recebido o polimento nenhum agora eu não
teria nem aqui se eu fosse uma pessoa do
mal o público que acompanha sabe que eu
não estaria aqui você me chamou não é
por não sinto que você me chamou aqui
o sensacionalismo ou por você não
precisa disso Você não precisa desse
tipo de engajamento e isso é bem nítido
nossas coisas que você faz na sua
personalidade então eu aceitei vi porque
eu já te conheço eu sou uma fã eu
acompanho seu trabalho eu admiro muito a
a clareza EA coragem que você teve
dispor só depressão na época Me tocou
muito porque foi uma época que eu tinha
assim falava a gente ninguém fala sobre
isso direito eu não falo então pra
vergonha de falar tá vendo e aí se eu
não falasse você nunca saber não ele
Talvez aí eu chegasse para você aí dois
barraco com você no corredor de um de
uma emissora e tudo mais a gente tá
conversando e tudo mais você passar por
mim você não ia saber tá ligado né tu
passa que eu passei Sinto Sinto que eu
pensei disso mas e aí a gente não tem a
gente no rádio e às vezes o dia que tem
que reagir tá ligado já passei muito
tempo com vergonha de mostrar minha
fragilidade de me expor como fraca
o que tem Nossa coisa na minha cabeça de
ser mulher preta para muitas pessoas é
um saco esse assunto de preta preta
página para mim que sou preta também eu
acho um saco mas eu reconheço os trocas
disso mas tem que falar às vezes eu
penso a vida inteira vai ser isso a vida
inteira Vou ter que ficar falando
sofrimento que é ser uma mulher preta
respondo exemplos por que que eu como
mulher preto foi cancelada nessa
situação se outra pessoa branca fez pior
ou igual e não teve esse cancelamento do
a picanha e que a gente fez e ganhou
ganhou que teve gente que disse e Fulano
assaltou o condomínio e ele nem parecia
perdido era branquinho assim tá vendo e
ganhou entendeu E aí não querem que eu
pense que algum problema está
relacionado à questão da negritude eu
falo não não é possível mas porque aí eu
começo a pensar Ah entendi eu como
mulher preta tem que ser quieta submissa
e não reagir eu não posso opinar nada é
sempre hahaha a gente pode ver
claramente que rolou nesse reality agora
que tiveram dois participantes pretos e
o público tava até então não tinha
problema nenhum com eles que o João EA
Camila chamavam de planta quando eles
decidiram ou se sentiram a necessidade
de expor opinião ou se defender de
alguma situação o público acabou a não
eles são chatos a já vem lá eles com
esse papo de militância só a verdade
aqui o preto ele sós
e na sociedade ou na televisão quando
ele tá sofrendo ou quando ele está
calado e submisso começa a reparar e
fazer uma reflexão de todos os artistas
que demonstraram um pouquinho se não
teve gente achando estranho pega tira
minha cor tira a cor de outra pessoa
pega a mesma atitude Veja a o peso da
reação das pessoas existe sim o errei
óbvio não tô justificando nem negando
mas existe também um erro da parte do
público em julgar sempre com mais peso
mais mas acidez quando o a personalidade
é preta
Ah entendeu Essa pode ser a mais querida
de todas igual aquele no reality ele
temos personalidades pretas queridas sem
acidez que eu tive sem a sua revolta mas
também estão sendo julgados EA pauta é
porque são negros ou é o cabelo é porque
se sentir o dolorido com alguma coisa é
um saco coisa que todo mundo fala toda
vez meu filho Toda vez é estudar vale a
caminhada dessa forma e agressividade da
mulher preta porque ela foi agressiva
porque ela tem isso ou teve gente também
é Teve gente que chegou para ti e falou
para ti também tipo assim você tá
continuando o estereótipo da mulher
preta barraqueira não muito triste
porque não tinha consegue te ajudar esta
na mesma causa disso porque era uma
coisa que não é
eu ia fazer Óbvio que não quer mas a
minha vida eu aprendi para ser ouvida
respeitada era só o barraco foi o que eu
aprendi e algumas amigas pretas minhas
também tá muito complicado falar de
sistemas Muitas pessoas não levam a
sério eles preferem levar mais a sério
ódio coletivo do que as camadas que me
levaram até atitude espécie mas quando
eu conto alguma coisa né de racismo o
que aconteceu perto de mim porque tipo
eu não posso falar sobre a cena que eu
não passo eu isso né Isso não vai
acontecer comigo contra o branco não tem
racismo é tá conceito Talvez tu
preconceito é um pré-existe ver você
dentro tem antes de conhecer a pessoa
não é o sentido literal da palavra
preconceito que leva você fala de
racismo é pode ser um preconceito mas o
racismo não tem porque a minha raça
nunca passou por tantos anos de
Sofrimento igual
e todo mundo passou né então tipo assim
chega para mim um que acontece com o
teste comigo eu falo com Eu tenho um
amigo Robson por exemplo Robson cara que
anda comigo e constantemente as coisas
acontecer com ele e constantemente eu tô
junto entendeu então tipo ovos olha para
mim o Robson não disse para mim tu
resolveu o que em caso de racismo que
aconteceu alguns olha para mim e eu falo
assim
e quando eu tenho que tomar atitude o
tomate Tude por quê Porque se o erro é
da minha galera Então sou eu que tô
corrigir uma galera né Não não é você
que tem que ficar falando que o cara tá
errado porque o cara tá sempre a vida
inteira não vai não vai mudar porque tu
tá falando eu quero vai achar que aquele
lá e aí eu vou lá e fala com o cara por
exemplo vamos vamos resolver o problema
do Robson chegar comigo a galera acha
que o Robson é o meu segurança [ __ ]
Robson é grandão o Robson aí ao tão
então Robson meu segurança né porque ele
anda comigo o Robson motorista né porque
o Robson tá comigo eu tô lá e fala tudo
bom tudo bem aí vou comer e o cara fala
e o motorista não come não aí eu falo
assim né
e vamos resolver Robson quando a gente
chega em outro lugar eu já chego tudo
bom mamãe isso aqui é o Robson e o
roteirista entendeu então tipo assim eu
dou o meu eu dou o meu eu posso fazer
que eu não tenho muito o que fazer a não
ser tipo falar para o cara parar de
achar que tem chega comigo e a grande é
preto é para segurança ou é motorista
entendeu então tipo até acontecer uma
verde ou tá com ele no banco e eu falo
assim como eu eu tava sacando dinheiro
fala Robson comigo lá dentro tal Porque
eu tenho medo que as pessoas sei lá sim
eu sempre ando com alguém lá não dá
logicamente você não olha quando a
pessoa que anda com você Você anda com
alguém né [ __ ] [ __ ] e aí eu tô lá
com Robson e fala assim Robson bolsa
aqui cinco mil para nós fazer tal coisa
para ele fica aqui comigo aí eu fosse
sacana eu vou dando Robson eu vou sacana
voltando para o outro essas roupas ai
e eu comecei a perceber que quem tá
vendo pela câmera de segurança lá dentro
tá vendo eu sacando e te dando dinheiro
aqui aí eu vou assim Robson eu tô sendo
é preconceituoso ou vindo para cá vida
Tá ligado não tem que ser eu tô torcendo
para você tá sendo precavido você já tá
você já tá irritando já tá visualizando
preconceito e tomando um cuidado viu com
isso a minha galera entendeu é uma
galera não chega perguntando Ah legal a
minha galera é assim que se ver você já
dando Gerais que você está sendo
assaltado né E alguém vai pode pensar
que também por por eu achar isso eu tô
achando que eu tô sendo preconceituoso
por achar ou eu tô sendo com tendo um
combate com meu amigo que eu tenho medo
pelo meu amigo tá ligado porque eu sei
porque o meu amigo já foi tipo já foi
autuado por que ele entrou na farmácia e
ele não coreografou o movimento que ele
ia fazer para ver um produto entendeu é
que tem isso tem que for e gravar mesmo
eu não fico fazendo assim ó e chegando
perto de mim as coisas porque o cara ver
na câmera e vai lá atrás de mim então eu
pego você mostra pro
e deixa bem e eu boto ele lá em cima de
novo tá ligado então tipo assim empurra
eu vejo um problema do meu amigo todo
dia todo dia todo dia todo dia todo dia
na Meus amigos chegam atrasado e OK aí
chega meu amigo atrasado e ele é folgado
porque ele chegou e ele é muito folgado
vou ter que demorou e ele esse aqui eu
falo gente mas todo mundo demorou cara é
a galera escola e ele passei o folgado
falei ele vai ser o cara tá ligado Então
eu falo com ele assim Robson às vezes eu
tenho vontade de falar porque eu tenho
vontade para falar mas eu não tenho como
chegar no teu lugar e falar entendeu
porque você é o cara que tem que falar
mas às vezes eu tenho vontade de falar
em gente dá um time com o Robson mas
fale porque às vezes é só de branco para
branco que o anti-racismo funciona que
quando é um preto falando pessoa como se
fosse algo chatas o branco geralmente
têm preguiça fala ai que chatice esse
papo de novo e quando a gente fala da
e tud do branco não é da pele branca ou
de você branco é de um sistema branco e
quando o branco racista fala do preto
ele não fala nem do sistema negro porque
não é como se não existisse na sociedade
e aí ele fala do indivíduo do preto
preto esse da pessoa é preto que nem no
meu caso já tinha que ser preta entrou
no reality acabou com tudo só Os Pretos
que fazem cagada como se branco não
fizesse com a nada então tanto Preto
quanto brancos estão sujeitos a errar e
assumiu o erro existem vários tipos de
pessoas este aquela pessoa que é erra
assumir existe aqui nunca erra mas
quando errar vai dar um fina própria
vida porque tá montado na sua bebê
acredita que não pode errar é soberania
por isso que eu falo que eu desisti não
não combina comigo nem com meu look
porque quando você desiste de uma coisa
que deu errado é sinal de que você não
tá pra evolução Desde quando a evolução
ela tá ligada à perfeição
Ah entendeu então se você começa a
reparar umas coisas quando tem o
anti-racismo chegar a 100 porcento do
seu ser né É É só uma questão de tipo II
e o que é um movimento o movimento
anti-racista ele é o que na verdade é
você ir na internet e um belo dia no mês
#blacklivesmatter aí antirracista e
ainda uma oportunidade que você tem para
definir para acabar com o artista Preto
você vai lá e falar mas é porque é preto
não não pode levar rajadão pode a
questão é qual é o nível a intensidade
desse rajadão que você tá dando para
esse para essa figura Não tô dizendo que
eu não merecia ser linchada eu merecia
ser punida dentro do game né não agredi
ninguém fisicamente não não cometi
nenhum crime grave não tem as
intensidade Então por que será que não
tá ligado ao ódio encubado da mulher
preta se dizer tão poderosa ela sai
trombando tudo
é uma boa carreira porque quantas
histórias de mulheres mulheres pretas na
música A gente tem que sofrer no
cancelamento tem várias entendeu tiveram
artistas pretas aqui do Brasil que
contribuíram para o meu lixamento
artistas essas que também já foram
linchados e canceladas então você vê que
o negócio ele não vai artista Preta se
fala como uma mulher uma artista preta
que é constantemente cancelada e
linchada na internet por ter a vida
viver do jeito que quer por cantar a
música que canta ela vai ela ajuda no
lixamento inventa situações E aí depois
de uma semana ou duas você vê essa
pessoa sendo cancelada de novo ou tendo
alguma ação na justiça que não foi legal
você vê que o mundo ele gira
é E essas mesmas pessoas pretas que
cancelam pessoas pretas que falam em
nome de Deus tão fazendo atitudes piores
e o que aquela personagem que eu já não
gosto nunca gostei que a Karol Conká
dentro do BBB como acontecer com pessoas
que chegavam para mim falar você viu aí
eu falava não nosso isso não mas eu vejo
no Twitter tá eu vi uma coisa lá lá até
assim eu fui perto da pessoa isso e a
pessoa aquilo ali é podre podre mas é o
ser humano por dentro já está apodrecido
e eu lembrando de Atos que a pessoa fez
tá ligado Tipo assim cara então tá
caindo os pedaço de pudim é E aí
aproveitando dia quem tá falando de
reality né porque eu vi lá dentro né na
nos looks nas conversa e tudo mais você
gostou da parada mais espacial mais
Universal e mas ele n Jenna E aí sabe o
que aconteceu porque esses dias eu tava
na minha varanda E aí eu tava pensando
assim [ __ ] ia ser muito legal seu
vice
e agora e aí quando deu alguns minutos o
que eu falei isso não viu o militar não
tem gente que você tomou você sabe o que
que dá você gostar de Karol Conká gente
não é possível mas o que que saiu uma
teve 11
eu vi
e ele tava parado
a missão de pensar não tá piscando
passam de cópia Mas como ele ele anda de
lado Nossa e a florescente né
e olha a
e não e avião não faz isso linda
E aí ele faz um e segue in
já parou para o ar
E será que ele sabia que estava olhando
ele meu Deus é sempre nesses lugares que
eles aparecem e não tem com os assim ó
Oi gente Eu Tô chocada eu quero ver ao
vivo comigo é
o meu Deus gente não não meu Deus do céu
meu Deus são dois me falou assim ó olha
aí ó
E aí
o Brasil não é um
e olha olha outro um dois três eram três
Que lindo olha a cor meu Deus do céu meu
Deus e o povo me chamando de louca e aí
eu tava devendo lá no big brother falei
carai ela fala do dia dela ficar livre
daquele E aí eu vi esses dias já veio ou
não não que eu saiba mas tem vontade de
ver eu tenho vontade de ver eu creio
neles e quando eu falava assim no dia
que eu ganhei a liderança eu ficava
assim é o Desde o dia que acordei eu
falava eu sou a nova líder só a nova
líder eu sou de Deus parem comia corra e
eu ficava a semente só falar vai para cá
E aí eu viajei porque como eu tenho toc
Eu tenho um toque real que nem da hora
que você coisa aqui eu já tava olhando
como é que tá as fitinhas ali e aí falta
uma nele porque está 222 aí não tem a
segunda ali todo
e olha a última Olha a última Olha lá só
tem uma eu tava tô Incomodada com isso
que não mandou e eu falo uma só olhando
alí e aí eu vejo que tá faltando uma
lida eu fico na minha cabeça eu imaginei
eu tirando de algum lugar botando aí
ficou assim e aí eu tava assim na prova
eu falava essas Mangueiras aí deixa eu
ver essas Mangueiras freio nossa tem
umas que estão conectadas as outras não
tão a viagem da louca no rolê né e eu a
vou nº 21-a 2011 já foi vou no 17 foi 17
a gente sabe como que eu vi eu vi que a
mangueira tava conectada e isso era uma
coisa que eu achei quem libera a água na
prova é a produção não é aquela
mangueira que teria que ir a um cenário
Oi e eu na minha cabeça por ter notado
se eu notar alguma coisa fora do encaixo
eu já nota aqui eu já vejo rápido se eu
tô assistindo um filme eu vejo problema
com continuidade eu vejo tudo isso então
ali a minha cabeça mexendo eu tenho que
me livrar do paredão eu ficava assim ver
se era para me livrar do paredão né que
era um bate-volta aí eu olhei e comentei
não a mangueira mangueira não tava e
aqui fora o povo Nossa ela tá passeou
Por que a Globo Então imagina a cabeça
da produção desse programa com a minha
loucura ela dentro toda hora tudo que eu
falava parecia que eu tinha recebido e
eu não recebi eu não recebi mesmo não
recebi se eu tivesse recebido essa
altura no ponto da loucura já foi mal
recebi mesmo vale mas eu falava obrigada
Deus obrigada e ter e aí eu perguntava
porque os ets tem Deus mas você que
acredita em Deus acredita em ET eu falo
assim
E qual o problema Eu acho que o até tá
ligado a Deus também porque e também se
ele não não tá na terra tipo a morada
dele não é aquele tipo no céu ele
extraterrestre não é uma coisa muito
diferente só longe daqui não quer dizer
que ele tem a mãozinha pequenininha
Verde céu ele é festa né porque boa em
outro dizer que eles são parecidos com a
gente você precisa saber eu ouvi dizer
mas é que eu vi os ufólogos alguns
vídeos eu falo que eu tô falando isso
que pra ficar bem quanto Quem são eles
eles são extremamente educados já sei
que eu não sou e tempo que na casa foi
extremamente explicação né bem mal
educada mas o certeza eles são bem
educados acho que não come e não bebe
chá de camomila e
Oi Carol obrigado por você ter vindo
aqui conversar comigo e e como você
falou tipo expor suas fragilidades né
porque quando você vai no lugar você ou
você chega antes de fala assim eu não
quero falar sobre tal coisa ou você
chega lá e fala assim para você mesmo né
Vamos lá conversar e vamos ver o que que
é aí você veio aqui você vai ter um papo
é eu sou assim o negócio é encarar de
frente o brigada brigada por esse espaço
pela pelo acolhimento pela empatia às
vezes às vezes a gente tá fazendo a
praticando a tá da empatia sem nem saber
né no caso né porque a interesse meu tem
também Lógico que eu tô conversando nós
estamos juntos aqui no mesmo lugar sei
que isso vai gerar uma alguma coisa
galera vai assistir E aí aproveitando
isso a gente tem que aproveitar e falar
o que a gente tem vontade de falar
porque eu nem tinha vontade de expor
minha opinião sobre a estação de sim
curto muito que todo mundo odeia alguém
eu consegui minhas atitudes foram
odiáveis mas eu não sou uma pessoa do
mal e não eu não mereço ser odiada
minhas atitudes sim eu entendo o que que
você tá dizendo eu entendo que você tá
dizendo se incompreendido faz parte da
vida do artista é que é bom gente botar
na cabeça isso porque isso é
incompreendido faz parte da nossa vida a
gente fala meu qual é a senha do wi-fi
teve empresário o meu que disse para eu
não postar que faria mal para minha
carreira Porque fala de internet porque
eu mexo eu internet qual seria sem vai
fazer sim irmão tô criativo agora na
cabeça tá dizendo que sim então eu vou
nessa e tudo mais então tipo a gente
sabe que a cabeça da artista é muito
doida é e a gente nasceu para ser uma
coisa realmente diferente não adianta a
gente dizer que a gente quer ser um
civil normal e trabalhar no no lugar
comum que a gente não consegue a gente
não consegue a gente gosta de se
expressar assim que trabalha a gente vai
falar assim vai cantar um rap que nem
você falou assim é um reto ali galera
e não faz rap que aqui do seu lado seu
artigo está espremendo tanto que tá
saindo assim ele tá transbordando já
então é a nosso destino isso aqui não
tem muito não tem muito obrigado por
você ter vindo aqui você ser que
agradeço você se real comigo obrigada
obrigada a gente já O que atrai eu fui
real sou real Você é real aqui
conversando para todo mundo de alguma
forma que é para quem tá aqui
conversando a gente conversar para se
entender o que ela me entender sim
superintende sinto muito pelo que eu
casei para todo mundo mais uma vez vamos
seguir qualquer coisa me bota no seu
coração qualquer coisa me fala se você
gostou não esquece de clicar em gostei
comentar aqui embaixo que você quer ver
por aqui algum dia e o que que você
tirou de legal
e essa conversa me dá se você quiser
comentar aí deixar sua análise a gente
já sabe que você é um psicólogo e você é
um terapeuta você sabe de tudo então
fique tranquilo desde a opinião aí que a
gente vai lá e todas as 15 mil e tantos
que tiver Então é isso aí não esquece de
seguir Karol Conká lá seguir e ver os
novos trabalhos os meus trabalhos novos
também nos nossos projetos cutilar me
segue tamo junto é nós respeito a bacia
e
o casamento é
eu tô sentar sem erros e
a placa de 33